hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll this
is the April 2023 ask me anything
edition of mindscape and I thought I
would start out by telling a somewhat
amusing story about last month's AMA
episode the March 2023 episode you know
I start off each episode with an
introduction if it's a regular podcast
I'll talk about the guest and the topic
if it's an AMA I'll just Ramble On for a
little bit uh maybe with some
information about what I'm doing lately
or whatever so last month I was getting
you know still in the mode of having
moved to Baltimore having moved to Johns
Hopkins there wasn't a lot of big news
to talk about so I talked about the fact
that we had had a very mild winter in
Baltimore almost no snow
um I've never lived in Baltimore over
the winter before but I have lived in
Philadelphia it's not that different and
I use this to make a completely banal
observation about human psychology you
know as we know so we are facing a
crisis of global warming caused by human
beings the climate is changing this is
going to be bad in various ways now the
fact that we'd had a mild winter in
Baltimore this one year is not strong
evidence in favor of global warming it
is some evidence it's one little tiny
data point but you need a lot more data
than that it could just be a random
fluctuation that's not a big deal I was
not by any means making the claim that
the fact that we hadn't had any snow in
Baltimore is evidence for anthropogenic
climate change I don't think we need
more evidence for that we just had a new
ipcc report come out it's uh incredibly
overwhelmingly strong the evidence that
climate change is real it's being caused
by human beings the effects will be
disastrous the point I was making was
one about human psychology namely that
you can know intellectually that climate
change is happening and you can know
that it's bad and you can be in favor of
all sorts of ameliorating programs and
so forth but when your winter is warm
you think about it in a different way it
sort of hits home even if again you know
completely well intellectually it could
just be a random fluctuation like I said
a very mild banal observation that's
that was the intro to the podcast last
month
and as many of you know I put these
podcasts in addition to the usual audio
feeds all over the place that you can
find the podcast I put them on YouTube
as well there's no video it's just a
still image with me and the guest
talking but some people like watching on
video I don't mind doing it I lose money
doing it because I don't get the ad
revenue and it's it's work because I
have to make the video but I do want to
spread the podcast as widely as I can
usually it's not that many people who
prefer to listen on YouTube so that's
okay it doesn't really make a difference
I might get 5 000 listeners or whatever
the interesting thing about YouTube
though is you can go viral on YouTube
like you can with a tweet or with
something like that on various other
um social media because you're watching
a screen while you're on YouTube when
there's all these suggestions next to
you and if you finish a video we'll
suggest more videos this doesn't happen
interestingly for regular audio podcasts
because people listen to podcasts
they're driving their car or they're on
a walk or whatever with their earphones
they're not watching a screen most of
the time if they're watching a purely
audio listening to a purely audio
podcast so there's no way to get that
recommendation right to get the
suggestion to go somewhere else so
usually for my podcast I have a very
very stable audience the number of
people listening is more or less the
same it fluctuates plus or minus 10
percent
depending on who the guest is what the
topic is or whatever but it's basically
the people who subscribe to the
mindscape feed listen to mindscape on
YouTube that's very different so rarely
but occasionally something can take off
if it pushes a button last month's AMA
episode took off which is hilarious
because it's a three hour long ask me
anything episode about all sorts of
crazy topics but that
three or four minute intro somehow got
people's attention so instead of five
thousand
listens to that YouTube video like I
would usually get it's like 500 000
listeners which is absurd and guess what
they didn't like it so somehow the
YouTube algorithm was pushing my AMA
episode into the feeds into the
attention span of people who were very
against the idea of climate change and
that human beings are in charge of it
the climate denialists somehow got
pushed this AMA episode and you can tell
not just because the numbers are are
much bigger but they leave comments you
know you can read the comments
um you can't read them now you can't
because I delete the the worst ones but
there are some bad ones let's just put
it that way uh I leave the benign ones
up there even if they're wrong but but
completely uh crazy pants ones I will
just go ahead and delete and overnight I
got much worse reviews on that podcast
than anything else that I've ever put on
YouTube I don't know why I don't know
why that guy but pushed these people or
why they clicked on it right there's
nothing in the title nothing in the
description of the show knows that even
mentions climate change
somehow it must be so there's only two
possibilities one is that somehow it got
linked somewhere else but yeah that I
can't keep track but I suspect that the
YouTube recommendations are not just
generated by the text or the description
or the title but the actual audio right
that they're that they that YouTube
listens to your audio transcribes it
somehow and uses that to make
recommendations and so somehow I'm just
guessing this could be completely wrong
somehow YouTube thought that my podcast
was about climate change and so I got
all sorts of comments about how you know
you can see what kind of people it is
um oh I bet you believe that the Earth
is round too I bet you got vaccinated I
bet you think black holes are real
so yes guilty on all those uh
accusations sorry about that anyway I
thought that it was it was really
interesting because not only it's
Illuminating about the YouTube algorithm
but it's Illuminating about
as we all know we live in a
hyper-specialized localized information
ecosystem where you can choose to hear
what you want to hear and
it wasn't that long ago you know 10 or
20 years ago there is what I would call
a semi-respectable debate about climate
change all the respectable people knew
that climate change was real and that it
was it was problematic
um but there were plenty of sort of
semi-respectable people who were trying
to raise problems with it these days the
semi-respectful people will argue either
that it's too late you know the climate
has already changed too much we can't do
anything about it or that yes it's
changing and it's our fault but it just
costs too much to do something about it
that's where the semi-respectable debate
has shifted to uh just like there was a
semi-respectable debate 20 or 30 years
ago about intelligent design right I
mean there's a respectable debate and
the semi-respectable one today there's
not that many people even in the
semi-respectable sphere who deny the
reality of climate change or that human
beings cause it so since that's you know
where I get my information from the
union of the respectable and
semi-respectable I'm more or less not
paying attention to the completely
disrespectable disrupting well whatever
you want to call it uh spheres out there
and I I forget that they're there
there's a whole large number of people
who are really very very committed as an
important part of their self-image to
denying that the climate is changing and
that human beings are causing it so it's
educational for me anyway
um I'm just trying to say the words
climate change and denial and Flat Earth
enough in this intro so we can do the
experiment again see if it is once again
fed to people in their YouTube
algorithms I really I really don't know
one way or the other but other than that
we actually have a lot of good
um questions in this month's AMA and I
mean that like it was hard for me this
month to not answer all the questions
like I mean it's it's easy for me to not
answer all the questions because it
would take me six hours but they were
all really really good questions you you
folks are getting good at uh asking
these questions but you folks I of
course mean people who support the
podcast on patreon if you go to
patreon.com Sean M Carroll you can sign
up to support mindscape a dollar an
episode two dollars an episode or you
know pledge 100 episode I don't care I
will not stop you from doing that if you
do pledge any amount you will get to
off-road questions every month for the
AMA episodes as well as getting ad-free
versions of the podcast that you can
listen to uh and also it's nice and I
very very much appreciate the support
thanks for all of you folks out there in
patreon land and I will also um offer up
apologies I am going to Hope and try
that the audio quality for this episode
is good but I'm on the road now I'm not
at home with my usual setup with my
usual nice microphones and and non-ecoy
room and so forth so I do my best I try
very hard to make the audio quality good
but the mobile podcasting it is not
quite as reliable as the home studio so
we do our best and with that climate
change climate change climate change
let's go
[Music]
our first question is from Kyle Stevens
who says in your last AMA on black holes
being the source of dark energy you
stated that papers are often not worth
voting much thought to as they are
almost certainly wrong in their
conclusions I assume this paper and
others like this are written by
credentialed and educated academics what
then leads to the publication papers
such as the black hole Dark Energy paper
that aren't worth taking seriously do
the authors themselves not believe in
what they're writing so I've talked
about this kind of thing before but it's
a really important issue and I haven't
really succeeded I think in articulating
how I think about this
um you know very very briefly the
authors of this paper are certainly
believing what they're saying they're
being very very sincere they're very
excited that they got what they think is
a new and important result they're doing
it in good faith and earnestly that is
absolutely not the problem and other
people might completely agree with them
right I mean obviously this paper uh a
set of papers along these lines by these
group of authors got published so got
through the refereeing process got
through the editors Etc they have
colleagues who they've talked to I'm
sure so there's nothing intentionally
misleading or anything like that going
on here and I wouldn't even say that
it's almost certainly wrong what I would
say is it could be right I should I
should back up because maybe you don't
even know maybe depending on what your
uh background here is you haven't heard
about this but there was a claim in the
news and in the scientific literature
that black holes can grow in Mass
relatively faster than we think that
they do as the universe expands so
they're these people people did some
general relativity did some calculations
and they said that when you take a black
hole and you look at the solution to the
metric of space-time in general
relativity given by Einstein's equation
by itself the black hole could just sit
there and wouldn't grow but if you try
to look at what happens to the black
hole in an expanding universe so you as
a background in which you've embedded
the black hole you don't just take empty
space with nothing in it but you take an
expand the universe like we live in they
claim there is a cosmological coupling
so the black hole will grow in Mass all
by itself because it is living in a
universe that is expanding not because
there's an accretion disk or stuff
falling into it and in fact they say
that the expansion of the mass of the
black holes goes as the expansion rate
of the universe to some power the the
scale factor the size of the universe to
some power
and in fact
so here's what we'd ordinarily say like
if you're a regular Garden variety
conventional cosmologist you would say
the energy contribution to the energy
density of the Universe from black holes
is from the mass of the individual black
holes and we think that the mass remains
roughly constant and just like any other
particle which has a mass and its mass
stays constant as the universe expands
the total amount of energy in any region
of the universe stays fixed total number
of particles or black holes phase fixed
the total energy per particle or black
hole stays fixed so the total energy
stays fixed and therefore if you're in a
box in three dimensions it is growing by
some Factor the total energy density
will go down like the volume of the Box
going up so the scale factor is the
linear size of your box the scale factor
cubed is the volume of your box so we
would say that the energy in black holes
roughly speaking goes as the scale
factor to the minus three power okay
the total energy stays same the energy
density goes down as the volume goes up
that's the conventional story these
folks are saying that they've looked at
the equations in great detail and
there's very complicated equations you
can look at
and when you do that what you find is
that the mass of individual black holes
increases like the scale factor cubed
coincidentally enough
and so the total energy in black holes
in that region remains constant uh sorry
total energy density remains constant
the energy goes up this is just like
dark energy is supposed to do just like
the vacuum energy or the cosmological
constant is supposed to do and therefore
they claim that black holes can be the
dark energy and my the short version of
my claim is just that these people have
not done enough to convince me that this
claim is worth looking into
I could very easily be wrong you know I
have not looked into it very very
carefully and so the two things I want
to talk about are number one why would I
not be convinced and number two what can
someone do to convince me like that's
the actual intellectually interesting
question
um on the general relativity question
you know I I've done general relativity
a lot I wrote a book on it I have a
certain feeling personally for what the
equations of general relativity predict
in certain different kinds of
circumstances nothing in anything I have
ever learned or thought about would make
me think that a black hole embedded in
an expanding Universe would have its
mass just spontaneously increase like
the scale factor cubed I have no idea
why that would happen that is completely
contrary to everything that I've ever
thought about general relativity now
that's not again to say that I know it's
wrong because I've never sat down and
specifically solved these equations okay
but the people who are writing this
paper are not claiming that what happens
in our galaxy affects the black holes in
our galaxy they're claiming that what
happens in the whole universe affects it
and the thing about general relativity
is the equations are difficult the
equations are non-linear there are not a
lot of Exact Solutions that you can look
at so instead what you do is you look at
some Exact Solutions and you look at
some approximations and you build up you
look at numerical simulations also for
in spiraling black holes for example and
you build up some intuition for what
seems reasonable and what seems
unreasonable
and the claims in this paper just don't
seem reasonable to me in terms of what I
expect general relativity to be
predicting so that's my general
relativity part of the story it goes
beyond that because
if it were true the black holes were
gaining in Mass you know black holes
aren't fixed they they have motions
through space right and so in fact they
pull together each other they have a
gravitational attractive Force so you'd
expect that these black holes would fall
into galaxies and into clusters of
galaxies and we would notice that there
was a huge amount of mass in the form of
black holes and I don't mean by like
micro lensing or individually looking at
the black holes themselves but there's
three times as much energy in the form
of dark energy as there is in ordinary
matter and dark matter so I would expect
that this whole prediction of this model
says that galaxies and clusters of
galaxies are actually three times
heavier or four times heavier than we
would expect and that's not true we've
done the observations and that's not
true so they have to come up with
another story in which the black holes
actually repel each other and they leave
the galaxies and that's why we we
haven't noticed them there again that is
entirely in conflict with everything I
have in my intuition about how general
relativity works having said all that I
could be wrong right so how would they
convince me to read the paper and think
that maybe they were right because
there's a lot of papers that come out
you know it's easy to say well if the
claim is right then it would be hugely
hugely important therefore you should
spend time looking at it but that logic
doesn't actually work because that's
true for a lot of claims a lot of crazy
claims might be might have the feature
that if they were right it would be
really important but that doesn't mean
I'm going to spend time thinking about
them there's not enough time you gotta
pick and choose you have to do some
triage here and it can be difficult this
is you know if something that is
important now for other reasons that
have nothing to do with black holes and
dark energy which is why I want to spend
some time on it because there's this
whole fad now for doing your own
research when it comes to claims that
you don't agree with or you think that
the mainstream media is perhaps
misleading you in some way The
Establishment is hiding the truth from
you so you're going to do your own
research
and the people who like to do their own
research I mean for one thing they're
not actually out there performing
randomized controlled trials so hey
they're not collecting data they're not
acting like the actual scientists
they're reading other people's work and
they're drawing their own conclusions on
the basis of them and my point is that
that process of reading other people's
scientific research in an area that you
are not an expert in is a lot harder
than you might think because scientists
disagree with each other scientists can
be wrong so it's not that you know these
people who wrote these papers are
displeasing their own result or that
everyone disbelieves them it's that I
just don't think that the probability
that they're right is very high and so I
want to give you a little bit of the
insight as to why I came to that
conclusion which might be relevant for
other people doing their own research so
the point is that
you do have some expectations right none
of us enters the world of trying to
figure out science or the way the
universe works completely as a blank
slate we have a picture of how the
universe works we have priors we have
propositions to which we assign
credences that we say oh yeah this is
pretty likely this is not very likely
and so on and then we have evidence that
comes in and as good bayesians we update
so when you have a claim in a scientific
paper that goes entirely against
everything the reader might have
expected to be true it is your job as
the author to do two things number one
indicate that you get it
that you know that this sounds very
different than what people expected and
list the reasons why people might not
believe it okay so you're not giving off
the impression that you just solved some
equations and are taking the answers at
face value because like I said in
general relativity
the equations are hard to solve exactly
you have to interpret sometimes you know
what effects are important what effects
can be neglected what are the boundary
conditions and it's all very very
important and difficult and what makes
some people good at doing general
relativity
so when I read a paper like this I'm
looking for an acknowledgment that
here's what you might expect and here's
why we are different and then the other
thing of course is that that latter part
here is why your expectations are not
going to come true in this particular
case here is why your intuitions are off
and I didn't see that in these papers
all they're telling me is we've solved
some equations we got this result isn't
that awesome and I think that you know
you need more than that I'll give you
two examples and very very opposite
sides I don't wanna I don't want to talk
about these people too much because I
think that they are good scientists
they're trying to do their best I just
don't I'm just not convinced by their
answer and that's okay if it weren't for
like the media talking about it and
acting like it's very exciting it would
just be the usual process of scientists
talking to each other and and that would
be great maybe I'm wrong and maybe I
will eventually be convinced so one
example is I wrote a paper with Jackie
lodman saying that energy is is not
conserved in Quantum measurement and
some people say well that's just
perfectly obvious thing we knew that all
along but other people say no that's
completely crazy how could you believe
that so Jackie and I really tried to say
in our paper here's why you might not
believe it and here's why those reasons
don't apply here I think that's an
important part of what you have to do
I'll give you a completely other and I
this second example I do with great
trepidation because I don't want to Tar
people uh with with bad
associations but it sticks in my mind
the bell curve remember the bell curve
you know that book Charles Murray and
James hernstein from uh the 80s and it
came out in the 80s and it was talking
about a distribution of IQ Etc and uh
what the implications of that are for
public policy and I'm not an expert in
this stuff and I was just a college
student when it came out
but I you know I'm curious it was a big
deal when it came out people are still
talking about it today
and so one of the I didn't read the
whole book by any stretch of the
imagination but I did look at it I
opened it and uh and Page through again
to do this judgment is this worth my
time right that's the question and one
of the very first questions I I asked
myself was you know look
there have been a lot of claims over the
years that I can do science and show
that some people some racial groups are
dumber than others right and these
claims have a very bad history of being
bad science badly done because people
wanted the results to be true because
it's a bunch of white people saying that
black people are dumb usually
historically that's what it's been and
these uh historical examples have been
used to justify some terribly racist
things so when a book comes along in the
1980s which purports to be super duper
modern and scientific uh but yet
reaching conclusions that are very
similar to conclusions that have been
reached 100 Years Ago by
pseudoscientific nonsense people what
I'm looking for is once again an
acknowledgment you might worry that this
is just pseudoscientific racism because
that's been we've had a long history of
pseudoscientific racism and here's why
we are not that
so when you open the bell curve you do
not find that discussion in fact you
find that they cite some of the
pseudoscientific racism of the past
approvingly and at that point I said Eh
this is not really going to be worth my
time and every individual person every
individual scientist is going to draw
those distinctions differently again
it's
just not enough time in the world this
is a point that zainab tupacy made in
our podcast conversation the most
valuable thing that people have to deal
with right now in the world is their
attention what do you spend time
thinking about and there are hundreds of
papers scientific papers coming out just
in fields that I care about every day
and I'm not going to read all of them
and and leave through them sadly I
probably read fewer than I should
because I'm busy doing other things but
you have to really think about what is
going to be most likely to pay off and
just because a result would be really
really important if it were true doesn't
mean it's going to be worth reading
because you don't think it's likely to
be true and this can happen with very
very well-known people I once went to a
talk by a very very well known physicist
but someone who you know bless his heart
it was known for exaggerating a little
bit and he gave a usual sort of
bombastic exaggerating talk and
afterward people were just not that
excited and you know we were chatting
afterward about other things and he said
it's like why weren't people excited
about my talk I'm claiming all these
amazing things I didn't know what to say
but you know the truth was like dude you
claim these amazing things all the time
they never turn out to be true so we
have a we have a filter a little bit and
and that's what's hard to get across to
people who are trying to do their own
research you know when you when you read
a paper
uh you can't just say oh look this paper
found this result therefore it's true
like everyone knows that but you know
how do you judge whether it's true well
who are the people what are they saying
how are they framing it do they seem
reasonable do they seem open to
understanding why they might be wrong or
they more rigid in their ideology and
pushing an agenda are they a little bit
too enthusiastic about their own results
so they're perhaps insufficiently
skeptical there's a lot that goes into
it and It's Tricky
but anyway I do not mean any way to
disparage the individual researchers
here I think that they're absolutely
doing their best and they might be right
I'm just explaining why they have not
yet moved me personally to spend time
digging through those long complicated
equations they've got to explain to me
why all of my intuitions about general
relativity are being violated in this
case
okay that was a longer rant I actually
thought about turning this into a whole
solo podcast but I think that's enough
10 minutes of yammering about this is
more than enough okay let's go on to
venkatas Mork Venus hope they got that
right who says Let's assume we live in a
simulation then it might be the dark
matter and dark energy are just
parameters set by simulation Runners EG
to confuse us would it mean we'd never
be able to resolve their mystery or on
the contrary this lack of this
resolution could prove the simulation
hypothesis
but this is an even less likely to me uh
potential hypothesis to explain dark
energy than the black holes are so not
again not trying to give uh venkitas a
hard time here but you know yes it is
absolutely conceivable that we live in
the simulation it is absolutely
conceivable that things like dark matter
and dark energy are just parameters set
by the simulation Runners
um in some sense I think everything
about physics and cosmology would
qualify as a parameter of the simulators
right someone's got to set these
parameters somehow we usually think that
nature does it but if we live in a
simulation then some simulator did it at
some point the idea that they did it to
confuse us I find pretty wildly
unrealistic like why do they care about
us that much like it took 14 billion
years of evolution of running time
um to simulate 14b years of evolution
even to get to us you know are we the
only people here in the universe yeah
this seems like a really bizarre game to
play for them maybe it's all just a few
Cycles on the their super intelligent
iPhones for all we know so maybe it's
not a big deal but it just seems weird
to me more importantly the reason I
thought this was a good question was
what would it mean in terms of being
ever able to solve the mysteries of dark
matter and dark energy
um
I I don't know if I don't have an
opinion on whether or not simulators
could make the parameters of our
physical world such that we would never
be able to explain them that's something
I honestly don't know I do I am a
believer that at some level there are
brute facts in physics and cosmology
there are just true things that we
measure rather than explaining so I
don't even think that I would ever come
to the point where oh it must be
simulated it must be like set by some
god-like beings to make it that way I
could just say you know that's the way
it happens to be in our universe I'd be
perfectly happy with that in terms of
the lack of resolution proving the
simulation hypothesis that I think is
very very unlikely
um for one thing how do you ever know
that you've cannot explain something
right we try like science tries to
explain things tries to come to better
understandings of things but there's
never you know known indication that
okay you have failed perfectly
irrevitably irrevocably you cannot
possibly explain this thing that you're
thinking about that's just you know
there's never a side like maybe you just
haven't done it yet and in fact this is
kind of relevant to various questions in
modern physics like there are some hard
questions is it possible that we'll
never answer them yeah it's possible but
probably we just haven't answered them
yet you know like be a little bit more
patient so I would say there's never
going to be a point where I would say oh
yeah we probably live in a simulation
because I don't know what the dark
energy is I think I know what the dark
energy is I think it's the cosmological
constant I don't know why it has the
value it does but we're still working on
that problem it's still very worth
exploring
okay I'm gonna group together
two questions I I apparently my
subconscious has put all the dark matter
and dark energy questions here at the
beginning so
Paul Conte asks given the amount of time
and the number of experiments that have
tried and so far failed to yield any
concrete evidence of dark matter if you
think it is time to give more
consideration to the Monde theories of
gravity Mond is milgram's Theory uh
modified Newtonian Dynamics which
purports to change gravity rather than
having a dark matter particle uh Paul
continues do you believe it is likely
that a dark matter particle may still be
discovered and Walter E Miller says if
it turns out there are no Dark Matter
particles but that the observational
evidence for dark matter is explained by
an adjustment of how gravity Works what
are the implications for our
cosmological models the value of Lambda
and the interpretation of the cosmic
microwave background
so again here's an example where maybe a
little more patience is warranted so in
terms of dark matter the first thing is
the evil the evidence that there is
something in the universe that we would
label and understand as dark matter is
overwhelmingly strong and I say this as
this is a testimony against interest I
wish it weren't strong I have worked
myself on the idea of modifying gravity
I think that would be cooler than the
idea of just another particle being the
dark matter but in terms of science when
you like sit down and look at the
theories and compare them to the data
the idea that dark matter is an
independently new propagating thing that
adds to the energy of the universe is
supported overwhelmingly by the evidence
mostly most importantly by The Cosmic
microwave background
um and I talked about this before so I'm
not going to go into great detail but
the cosmic microwave background and
isotropy is the small fluctuations in
temperature from place to place are
related to
fluctuations in density in both dark
matter and ordinary matter if there is
dark matter there and you can make
predictions based on your Theory of
physics for how the different amounts of
fluctuation the different scales across
the sky should be related to each other
and there's a story that you can tell
about the ordinary matter in the early
universe and it oscillates before
recombination before electrons have
joined together with protons to make
atoms the universe had a pressure in it
in the fluid because everything was
charged particles and the charged
particles would keep bumping into
photons and that creates pressure so
they were literally acoustic waves
literally sound waves a region of space
where the density of matter was slightly
higher than average would want to
collapse under its gravitational pull
and then it heats up because there's
pressure and it pushes back and it
bounces okay so you see these
fluctuations that have been evolving for
a while on small scales they have
bounced they've squeezed and bound
constant squeezed and bounced again many
times on larger scales maybe only once
or only half a time before the CMB the
cosmic microwave background was formed
and the thing is dark matter doesn't
bounce right dark matter just collapses
toward the regions where the gravity is
stronger so there's a very clear
unambiguous prediction in a universe
with dark matter versus the universe
without a dark matter in Universe
without Dark Matter These acoustic waves
will damp they will just get slightly
softer over time because you know the
over dense regions send out photons and
neutrinos and do over the underdance
regions and vice versa so you make a
prediction for how the different peaks
in the power spectrum of the microwave
background evolve as a function of scale
with dark matter there's a very
different prediction there's the same
basic story but now you have a new
ingredient the dark matter it doesn't
bounce so when the dark matter is in
Phase with the ordinary matter that
reinforces the density fluctuation and
therefore the temperature fluctuation
when it is out of phase it comes it goes
against the density fluctuation and
Smooths out sort of compensates a little
bit for the overheating in the ordinary
matter and so there's a difference in
the first third fifth peak of this power
spectrum of the CMB versus the second
fourth sixth the even numbered Peaks odd
versus even number Peaks a difference
between the odd and even numbered peaks
in the power spectrum of the cosmic
microwave background is incredibly
strong evidence for Dark Matter it is
evidence that there is a gravitational
pull that is being sourced by something
other than ordinary matter and that is
exactly what we see in the data it is
incredibly uh it was a prediction made
ahead of time that came out to be true
and guess what people who care about
modified gravity also made a prediction
and their prediction ahead of time was
that you should not see these
differences in fluctuations and that
prediction came out wrong when we
compared it to the data so why do we pay
attention to bond theories at all the
answer is what do you mean by a modified
gravity Theory generally when you start
with a modified gravity Theory you have
to like write down some actual Theory
like Milgram posited a phenomenological
model that would work in galaxies he
wasn't trying to explain the microwave
background or anything like that so
later people like beckenstein and others
have actually come up with good old
respectable field theories that give you
Mond like behavior in galaxies
to do that you need to invent new fields
and those new Fields vibrate and
propagate and have energy and so the
people who invent new theories of
modified gravity figured out that they
can explain the cosmic microwave
background data by inventing new fields
that propagate and have energy and move
around in ways other than the ordinary
matter moves around
so that's how they can claim to fit the
cosmic microwave background but guess
what that's just dark matter they just
have dark matter they have new fields
that propagate independently that we
haven't yet seen in experiments that's
just what dark matter is that's all it
is so I'm totally happy with the idea
that gravity is modified I would be
thrilled if that were true that would be
you know a playground for theoretical
physicists I would love it but there's
overwhelmingly strong evidence there's
something out there besides ordinary
matter that is causing gravity in the
universe so we haven't found the Dark
Matter particles yet that's true what is
the probability that we should have
found them by now that's a good question
people sort of don't ask that question
as much as they should they're they're a
little bit less willing to put their
money where their mouth is when it comes
to these things but what you can do and
I've done this is go back you know 20
years before we had a lot of the data we
have from current experiments and say
what are all the different possibilities
what what is the space of parameters
that we had in mind for what the Dark
Matter could be and how does it compare
with what we've actually looked for and
ruled out yet
very very very roughly the answer is
that we've ruled out about half of the
parameter space for weekly interacting
massive particles which are the most
popular Dark Matter candidate so that's
you know half is substantial but it's
not everything it's not 99 so it's not
like we looked everywhere the Dark
Matter could be and haven't found it yet
that's completely false
furthermore the Dark Matter might not be
weekly interacting massive particles
there's great evidence that there's dark
matter but we don't know what it is it
might just be axions for example those
were always the second most popular
candidate and we have not ruled out any
substantial region of parameter space
for Axion Dark Matter yet
it's completely possible that the Dark
Matter particle is something we haven't
thought of yet it just needs to be
something that moves slowly that is
massive and that doesn't interact with
photons very strongly you know that's
really all you need that's not very hard
to come up with models there have been
thousands of models uh predicted not all
of them are easy to experimentally test
the reason why axions and weekly
interacting massive particles are so
popular is because they are not only the
dark matter they were actually
originally proposed to solve completely
different problems and if you can solve
two problems with one particle then
that's considered a Triumph so look the
Dark Matter might just be axions it
might be a weakly interacting massive
particle we haven't discovered yet or it
might be something completely different
these are all viable possibilities and
the fact that we haven't discovered them
today and might not have discovered them
by next month doesn't mean they don't
exist you have to keep thinking having
said all that if someone comes up with a
better Theory then that would be great
the better Theory will almost certainly
involve new prop obligating amounts of
energy because that's what the CMB tells
us to believe in
Rue Phillips says as a fellow physicist
lover of Jane Austen I would very much
like your perspective on the author's
genius take Pride and Prejudice for
example comparing my feelings of reading
the book and my feelings after watching
the faithful a e adaptation I must say
that so much more is infused in the
adaptation that Austin does not capture
in words feeling romance Etc having read
other books of hers I believe it is her
style she Masters the character like no
other but also leaves something wanting
aside from being a groundbreaking female
novelist of her time period what do you
see as her genius and shortcomings
love this question I don't get enough
chances to rhapsodize about Jane Austen
here on the podcast or the amas or
anywhere else so I think I don't quite
agree with uh your
um diagnosis there Rue but I get it I
get what you are saying I just put it
slightly differently so the thing about
Jane Austen is I don't know maybe many
of the people listening have read Jane
Austen or our fans many probably have
not so she's a novelist who you know
what the plot's gonna be okay you don't
read Jane Austen novels for the plot
except that you know it's going to be a
happy ending the female protagonist is
going to get married and live happily
ever after so that you're not there for
the twists and turns of you know
Sherlock Holmes or Miss Marple kind of
story uh what you maybe are there for
but but I guess my point would be what
you might be there for comes in
different layers you can absolutely read
Jane Austen's novels at a completely
surface level and go along with it enjoy
the fantasy because like as Rue says
she's really a genius at I mean Rue says
uh character but I would put it a little
bit differently what Jane Austen is a
genius at is we all have our romantic
Adventures or Misadventures or
experiences or whatever and you know in
retrospect when you think about what was
going through your mind and what you did
when you were
infatuated with someone or dating
someone or someone you know you you go
boy I was really kind of silly back then
I did silly things I obsessed over silly
things I did not say sensible things
anyway if you're like most people
including certainly me
um and Jane Austen is really quite good
at going into exactly all of those
little obsessive things you worry about
when you're thinking about the object of
your affection Etc like every word you
said every word they said what does it
mean do they like me do they like like
me all of these things and and you can
enjoy that given take the specifics of
the journey to the Happy Ending are
quite well done and you can enjoy it for
that and that's what makes for good
movies
um but I don't think that's what makes
her a genius that's not that's not quite
enough other people can do that for me
what makes Jane Austen a genius is that
there's a quite substantial Gulf between
the words on the page and what Jane
Austen wants you to think
and there is enjoyment in figuring out
what it is that she wants you to think
because it's not like hopelessly
esoteric or hidden like if you put a
little effort into it you can figure out
what she wants you to think but you
absolutely need to put that effort in
the most obvious example you know
there's the famous opening line in Pride
and Prejudice where she says it is a
truth universally acknowledged that a
single man in possession of a good
fortune must be in want of a wife and I
I had a friend who read the book and
objected to this you know no it's not
true that a single man in possession of
Good Fortune must be one of a wife
that's a very bad thing to start a novel
with uh you know to be fair this was not
a native English speaker and they didn't
perceive the sarcasm you know clearly
Jane Austen was not trying to be serious
and this is you know the most obvious
thing I think most native English
speakers would not take that expression
in the first line of Pride and Prejudice
as serious okay but it goes way deeper
than that I mean just to give a couple
examples in Pride and Prejudice
Elizabeth Bennett who is the protagonist
her father Mr Bennett is portrayed you
know in part because we're seeing him
through Elizabeth's eyes as you know a
good man uh maybe a little grumpy
sometimes Etc but smart and kind uh
compared especially to Elizabeth's
mother who is portrayed very badly
but if you actually look at how he
behaves in many ways he's not that great
you know
um he's careless he sort of removes
himself from the cares of his family he
does not provide for them after he dies
they're going to lose the house they
have no special means of support Etc you
know in many ways you could easily say
that he is not that great but the novel
never says he's not that great he the
novel just shows you him not being that
great and lets you figure it out an even
better example
for those of you who have read the book
you know that the reason why Elizabeth
and her family are going to lose the
house when her father dies is that the
will is going to give it to his cousin
um uh Mr Collins right the Reverend Mr
Collins and so Mr Collins visits with
the idea of wooing one of the daughters
of Mr Bennett and then the house would
stay in the family and he actually
proposes to Elizabeth and she refuses
him because he's terrible I mean he's
just a a nincompoop and that's
absolutely believable because Elizabeth
is a hopeless romantic and she thinks
that she's going to hold out for
something better and that's all that all
makes sense but then Elizabeth's best
friend or that Lucas
also gets later gets proposed to by Mr
Collins and accepts his proposal and
from Elizabeth Bennett's point of view
this is crazy like why would you pledge
your life to this terrible terrible
person you're going to be miserable and
Charlotte explains you know this is this
is the best she can do these are the
options that she has and I think that a
lot of people reading the book are like
oh poor Charlotte she made a mistake you
know Elizabeth stuck it out and she
eventually got to marry Mr Darcy who is
much more rich and a wonderful person
and a loving husband Etc I don't think
that's the full story or anything close
to it many other I'm not you know the
first person to point this out but Jane
Austen is telling you sure I'm gonna
give you a fantasy about living happily
ever after but I want to remind you that
life is not a fantasy for most people in
the real world it makes perfect sense to
do what Charlotte Lucas did given the
position of women in that Society in
that period of time so Jane Austen is
both letting you enjoy the happy story
of Lizzie Bennett and Mr Darcy but also
not letting you forget that life was not
like that for everybody and this happens
just over and over again in many many
different ways in Jane Austen's novels
and that's what I really uh love about
them I don't you know in terms of
shortcomings she obviously wrote about a
very narrow slice of possible things in
the world I don't even think that's a
shortcoming like that's what she did I
think that's that's good I don't want
every novelist to write about you know
the widest possible Landscapes Etc I
think that Jane Austen for what she did
it was more or less ideal so I'm not
going to talk about her shortcomings
there
Charles Grant I Gotta Give shorter
answer to these questions oh my goodness
we're gonna be here forever Charles E
Grant says decades ago I was a physics
undergraduate my questions about the
philosophical foundations of quantum
mechanics were waved away with boar and
the Copenhagen School sorted all that
out I tried to read some of Bohr's
papers on the subject and found them
impenetrable recently I took a course in
the philosophy of quantum mechanics we
started by reading the epr paper
Einstein Podolski Rosen and it seemed
very clear I then tried to read Bohr's
response to the epr paper it was still
impenetrable to me I consulted my
professor and they sighed and said yes
Bohr is a very difficult read and folks
widely disagree on what he actually
meant Bohr was obviously a great
physicist but how did he come to be so
influential in the foundations of
quantum mechanics when his philosophical
writings were so difficult and
themselves subject to multiple
interpretations
yeah that's a very good question I think
it's a it's more of a historical
question than a physics question like
somehow the character of Niels Bohr did
manage to exert and a huge influence
over generations of physicists and if
you just read what he wrote it is a
little bit difficult to figure out why I
mean he's welcome to have his opinions
and his opinions could be even correct
sometimes uh he was clearly a genius
physicist due to his contributions to
quantum mechanics are unquestioned but
why uh were like you say his
philosophical writing so influential and
I don't know if you go back to the
podcast I did with David Albert we
talked a little bit about this and David
very uh amusingly said that if he were
able to have dinner with one person from
history it would be Niels Bohr and the
reason why is because the smartest
people in the world would go visit Niels
Bohr and then they would come away
spouting nonsense about the foundations
of quantum mechanics and David alvare
was very curious as to how board could
exert this power I think that part of it
was that Niels Bohr was a genuinely good
person and people really really liked
him you know John Wheeler who uh talked
a lot with Albert Einstein but worked
under Niels Bohr you know said that he
admired Einstein but he basically
worshiped Niels Bohr like Niels Bohr was
a saint as far as John Wheeler was
concerned and you know
um I think that there was something in
what four said that physicists wanted to
hear like they didn't want to worry too
much about the possible difficulties of
quantum mechanics they want to get on
with their lives and you know just do
the calculations shut up and calculate
and you know make some theories of
particle physics and radioactivity and
stuff like that but honestly I don't
know the details I don't know I
completely agree that for his actual
writings are very very hard to read I
would not suggest reading or even
reading epr as your introduction to the
foundations of quantum mechanics there
are other places you can go that are
much more modern and have sort of
figured out what the Deep issues are
Ken wolf says Joanna Hoffman said some
interesting things had some interesting
things to say about the future of cities
on a recent episode but she lost me
completely as soon as she said that her
ideal city would have at least 20
million people I am of the opinion that
there is a sweet spot of City size that
maximizes the available facilities and
venues while maximizing the ease of
navigating the city and I think that
sweet spot lies between somewhere
between half a million and 1 million
people based on where you have lived do
you have any preferences for City size
or thoughts on what would be the ideally
sized city to live in
I kind of want to say there's no such
thing as an ideally sized city to live
in this is definitely one of those areas
where I'd rather let a thousand flowers
bloom let a lot of different people have
different options which fortunately we
have in the real world right like we
have this weird weird thing right now
where our biggest cities are making it
very hard for people to afford to live
there
um I am what is labeled a yimby in the
discourse yes in my backyard as opposed
to a NIMBY no not in my backyard uh I
think we need to build a lot more
housing I think that's very very obvious
like that's the cheapest that's the best
way to make housing more affordable
build more of it and we don't do that in
our cities right now and that is a
problem but putting that aside I think
that
people are different you know in fact
not directly related to your question
Ken but we did talk about this in the
episode with Will Wilkinson on political
polarization and urbanization where you
know he talks about how different
personality types is classified by the
Big Five personality inventory are drawn
to either live in urban or rural
suburban environments and I think that's
good that's a feature not a bug so some
people are gonna like 20 million person
sized cities the number of options you
have uh for dining at 2 A.M will be
larger in a city of 20 million people
than in a city of half a million people
even a city of half a million people
just doesn't quite have the capacity to
support a lot of the more esoteric
small-scale idiosyncratic needs or or
wants or desires that that its
inhabitants might have I absolutely
appreciate what you're saying as someone
who lives in a half million person City
right now the ease of getting around is
just amazing I'd like to say that in
Baltimore like every point is 15 minutes
away from every other point in Baltimore
and there's like no two points in Los
Angeles that are 15 minutes away from
each other
um so the time it would take me to go
from one end of Los Angeles to another
would take me you know two different
states when I'm in Baltimore which is
great and wonderful but there is less
going on in Baltimore than there is in
Los Angeles and that's a trade-off and
that's absolutely fine there's plenty
going on in Baltimore you know more than
enough to fill my dance card as it were
but if you know there are people who get
out a lot more than I do and maybe one
more variety than that maybe they need a
bigger city that's completely fine with
them they're absolutely by the way
economies of scale I talked about this
also with Jeffrey West on one of the
original mindscape episodes
um there are things that just can happen
in important ways the bigger the city
gets so whatever individuals might want
I think that it is good for the planet
to have some cities with 20 million
people in them I think it's a perfectly
good goal to have
Sid Huff says the U.S government has
been dominated by just two parties for
nearly all of its history whereas
countries governed by parliamentary
democracy such as the UK Canada France
Etc typically have a number of parties
of varying sizes between four and eight
you recently taught a course at Johns
Hopkins on physics and democracy does
physics shed any light on why the U.S
has just two parties While most other
democracies have had multiple parties
I don't think you need physics actually
to address this question I think the
political scientists understand this
pretty well although there might be and
I'm actually thinking about this so I
can't give you a full-blown answer right
now but there might be a little bit of
insight You Can Shed by asking it asking
exactly that question from the physics
point of view but like I said there's a
perfectly conventional political science
point of view which is that well let's
put it in physics terms just because
that's what you asked and it's kind of
fun
um in physics terms what we're going to
do to describe the collective behavior
of and some object with many many little
constituents in it is invent some
emergent description right so I have the
table in front of me right here it's
made of a lot of little atoms but I'm
not going to describe it in terms of
atoms I'm going to describe it at a
higher level by talking about wood of a
certain size and tensile strength and
things like that so I invent a whole new
category of stuff table versus atoms to
describe this Collective behavior and
it's more or less unique that
description I mean I could describe the
table in different ways but the fact
that there is a table in front of me and
I'm going to group a whole bunch of
atoms together to call it a table makes
sense in a variety of objectively true
ways right I can describe the table
using a small number of data points
which gives me a handle over how it will
behave and things like that it's not
arbitrary why chop it up into a table so
in some sense there's an analogy there
with politics and with democracy you
have a bunch of people in your Society
in your country or what have you and
they come in to make a collective they
make a country or a state or a city or
whatever
um and that country or city or
Collective society makes decisions
um through a democratic process which is
kind of an emergent process right the
individual people have their individual
preferences and wants and so forth but
you have to somehow figure out how to
aggregate those into societal
preferences
here's the difference the difference is
that rather than the laws of physics
giving us the right way to describe this
emergent Behavior we have an extra layer
in the political discussion which is we
invent a system of government
even if you say well we have a democracy
okay how exactly is your democracy going
to work how are we going to vote is it
going to be uh plural out plurality
voting or rank Choice voting or approval
voting or some other system are we going
to vote directly for Representatives or
will we vote for people who vote for the
representatives how are we going to
split up power between a legislative
branch an executive branch and a
judicial branch and other branches and
so forth so all these choices
come into how we go about aggregating
the preferences of the individuals into
the what we call the preferences of the
societies and those choices and here's
what we actually answer your question
those choices go to a long way to
figuring out how political power is
fought for within the society in
particular the existence of political
parties very very roughly speaking to
oversimplify quite a bit the point in
the United States that we have a
president okay in a parliamentary system
you don't directly vote for the chief
executive you vote for your local
representative and then whichever party
gets the most Representatives can vote
for their leader the Prime Minister
again simplifying a lot here but that's
the basic idea
in that case you can have multiple
parties in the parliamentary system
because they can form coalitions if you
have multiple parties it'll very often
be true that no one party has a majority
so no one party can just pick the prime
minister so the different parties have
to come into a coalition to get together
and therefore a small party can have a
huge amount of power if one party gets
45 of the seats another party gets 45
percent of the seats and a third tiny
party gets 10 percent of the seats the
two big parties are going to fight to
make the little party happy so that they
can come into a coalition and uh choose
the prime minister right so there's
absolute power that is had by these
smaller parties whereas in the
presidential system where the people
just vote for their chief executive even
if it's through an electoral college
someone's going to win someone's gonna
lose right and basically
if you have a tiny party the chances
that you will ever win an election for
the president become vanishingly small
and so it's much harder to wield power
as a small party in a presidential
system than in a parliamentary system
you don't need physics to explain that
maybe you can think about it in terms of
physics but it's it's a pretty
straightforward result I think now is
that good or bad is a harder question
that I'm not going to answer right here
I think that people can argue over the
pros and cons I think there are both
pros and cons
um I'll just leave it at that you can
imagine what some of the pros are and
cons are yourself
James Swift says in your excellent
episode with Rafael miliere on how
artificial intelligence thinks he
discusses examining structures within
the large language models and the
question of whether they understand what
inputs they've been given this
immediately made me think about Mary the
color scientist the philosophy thought
experiment and whether this could be
considered in some way a real version of
that experiment and perhaps what it
would mean then to give a running model
in visual inputs which would be in some
way equivalent to experiencing red am I
connecting to things that I shouldn't or
is there something interesting there uh
no I don't think you're connecting to
things that you shouldn't but I'm not
sure there's something interesting there
or not you know to me the Mary the color
scientific so if you don't know the
merry color science experiment the idea
is
um although I certainly talked about it
in the podcast with Philip Goff for
example
um maybe also with David Chalmers I
don't remember the idea is that uh Mary
the color scientist grows up in an
environment where there are no colors
all that she ever sees in her life are
shades of black and white and gray but
she's a scientist and she learns by
reading books or watching YouTube videos
that have been grayscaled uh she learns
everything that there is to know about
color about the color red okay so the
the point of the thought experiment
which is first put forward by Frank
Jackson philosopher is
Mary knows every physical fact about
color she's a color scientist she's read
all the books etc etc then we let her
walk out into the world and see
something that is red for the first time
she now experiences something she gets a
kind of knowledge that she didn't have
before the knowledge of what it is like
to see the color red
therefore so the the premises of the
argument are Mary knows all the physical
facts before she leaves the room before
she leaves her environment she learns
Something New by leaving her room and
experiencing the color red therefore the
physical facts are not all the facts
there are facts that are not reducible
to the physical facts of science Etc and
therefore there's something about
Consciousness that is not just an
emergent physical phenomenon okay that's
the Mary the color scientist argument by
the way Frank Jackson I love pointing
this out he himself has repudiated the
argument he says it doesn't really work
I don't think it where I think it's kind
of obvious why it doesn't work
the question is you know from the
physicalist point of view like myself
someone who does not think that
um color the experience of seeing colors
is anything other than some way of
talking about what happens in our brains
at the physical level
what happens when Mary is in the room
reading physics books well certain
neurons in her brain act in certain ways
fires from certain synapses strengthen
some certain connections when she walks
out and sees the color red for the first
time different neurons fire and make
connections Etc that's it that's all
that's happening there's nothing in
there that should lead you to be
skeptical about physicalism or anything
like that you're just exciting different
neurons that's all okay anyway that's my
take on Mary the color scientist but in
terms of James's question what is the
analog there of what is happening in a
large language model so I so I'm not
exactly sure what uh you you're aiming
at in the question James but I I so I
don't think that there is any obvious
immediate analog of the large language
model experiencing something
that it couldn't experience without a
sensory input or something like that
that I'm not so sure you know like it
gets into questions of what it is a
sensory input you know large language
model is going to
get signals down a wire one way or the
other whether it's as typing them in at
a keyboard or whether it's hooked up to
a video camera
um what so what I do think is
interesting the interesting analogy here
is can you look into which parts of the
neural network that make up the large
language model the parameters of that
Network how are they changing when we're
giving it different information
and that is at least roughly analogous
but not the same as how the neurons in
our brain fire and strengthen
connections and so forth so what we
might learn is the difference between
quote unquote learning facts about color
and quote unquote experiencing the color
that those might be those are different
things we might learn something about
how they're different the nice thing
about a large language model is that
there are no
institutional review boards is that what
IRB stands for institutional view words
um you know that we have these boards in
academic scientific circles that tell us
how we're allowed to experiment on human
subjects and other kinds of subjects and
so they have rules and you're not
allowed to just open up someone's brain
and look at their neurons but you are
allowed to open up your neural network
and look at its neurons so maybe you can
learn something uh by direct
experimentation and prodding around that
we can't with human subjects on the
other hand
with human subjects those neurons have a
very definite spatial location and
topology and the different parts of the
brain have different functions in very
obvious ways that you can see with fmris
and things like that so it's less clear
in the case of large language models how
that modularization happens if it does
at all so this is an exciting Frontier
moving forward but I can't really
predict how useful it's going to be in
the in the near or middle term
red Antonov says considering how firmly
emergence has been entrenched into
Zeitgeist do you have a favorite example
of emergent Behavior or phenomenon
well I am not sure how firmly emergence
has been entrenched inside guys I guess
that depends on which Zeitgeist Corners
you are hanging out on uh certainly I
talk about it all the time but you know
whenever I talk about it I have to put
the caveat here that different people
use the word emergence for different
purposes or to mean different things so
I already gave you an example of just
the table you know tables and chairs to
me are perfectly good examples of
emergent phenomena in the sense that
they're describing the some aspects of
the collective behavior of many many
little tiny parts or that's a sloppy way
of putting it but perfectly accurate in
this case the less sloppy way of putting
it is
um there is a comprehensive description
of what is going on in the table that
involves Quantum field Theory and the
core Theory and electrons and photons
and all stuff like that and there are
less comprehensive
ways of talking about it which involve
tables and chairs and wood and things
like that and it doesn't really matter
that the more comprehensive theory is
made of little things that's the
distinction I'm trying to draw but it's
more comprehensive it is valid in a
wider range of physical situations
and the thing about the higher level
less comprehensive theory is that you
need less data to give a specification
of the system that's what emergence
really is I can accurately capture some
aspects of the physical behavior of the
system with way way way smaller amounts
of data there's a sort of many to one
map from the microscopic comprehensive
description to the microscopic immersion
description and yet we can still say
something real and true about Its
Behavior okay
um and in that case there's lots of
examples of emergent phenomena the table
is an example the motion of the Earth
around the Sun using just the center of
mass velocity and position is is a great
example air in the room being described
in terms of density and pressure and
temperature and velocity and things like
that these are all classic examples of
emergence now I will footnote that by
saying that there are some people who
use the word Merchant and will deny that
any of the examples I just gave you
count
because they want to use the word
emergence to only refer to those
examples where we don't exactly know why
the higher level Theory works okay like
as if there's not anything spooky and
mysterious about it then it doesn't
count as emergence to them uh and I
think that's exactly wrong like you can
define words whatever way you want go
ahead but I think it's not helpful to
restrict attention to the cases we don't
understand I think that we're going to
get better understanding if I really
really understanding the cases we
understand first and then expanding that
slowly to include things we don't
understand if you leap right to the hard
things uh it's going to be hard to get a
more comprehensive uh understanding
there okay so I don't know whether that
answered your question red but that is
my way of thinking about it
Brett Brent Meeker says Roy Kerr says
that penrose's Singularity theorem for
black holes doesn't actually apply in
the real world he says there's a
spinning object at the center of a black
hole
he points out that the solutions that
describe black holes are vacuum
solutions that a vacuum was just assumed
in finding the solution they are not
solutions for collapses of real bodies
are there any solutions even
computational ones for collapse of
matter into a spinning black hole and do
they treat the matter Quantum
mechanically so for those of you who
don't know Roy Kerr is the New Zealand
mathematical physicist who first derived
the solution to Einstein's equations for
a spitting black hole what we call the
Kerr metric and since most black holes
are spinning that is actually really
really important little piece of
knowledge to have and the singularity
theorems that he's referring to are
theorems first Roger Penrose proved the
first of them and then Stephen Hawking
and Robert Garrosh proved others these
are a set of theorems that show that
under certain assumptions when you have
collapsing energy and matter and so
forth it will form a black hole well you
will hit a singularity is the actual
content of the theorem then there is the
cosmic censorship conjecture which says
that every Singularity has a horizon
around it and is therefore a black hole
that's harder to prove it's not even
completely true in all cases but the
singularity theorems are saying you will
get a singularity in classical general
relativity so
I'm surprised that royker would say that
penrose's Singularity theorem doesn't
actually apply in the real world it is
absolutely true
that the exact solutions that we have
for black holes including the car
solution usually assume vacuum not
always there's the Risner Nordstrom
solution that allows there to be an
electromagnetic field for example and
there are some solutions for collapsing
shells of dust or matter or things like
that but those are usually perfectly
spherically symmetric that might that
makes our lives much much easier there's
only evolution in the radial Direction
over time you don't also need you're not
breaking the Symmetry by allowing the
thing to rotate so yeah as far as I know
there are no Exact Solutions to
Einstein's equations representing
collapse of matter into a spinning black
hole but the singularity theorem is
something different than that the
singularity theorem is the whole point
of it was that it is not an exact
solution it's an exact statement that a
wide variety of solutions will have the
following feature namely they get a
singularity okay so I think that's still
going to be true in the real world I
mean the assumptions behind it have to
do with the behavior of matter and then
that might not be physically accurate so
any theorem always has the feature that
if you violate the assumptions that you
use to prove the theorem then the
theorem no longer holds
um and as you allude to the end of the
question does that treat the matter
Quantum mechanically I mean I don't know
of any solutions to the equations of
general relativity that fully and
completely treat the matter Quantum
mechanically no so there's the idea that
well these two ideas one is that
whenever we talk about singularities in
general relativity we're cheating a
little bit because classical general
relativity ignores quantum mechanics I
think that's entirely true I think that
you should read the existence of
singularities In classical general
relativity not as evidence that there
are singularities in the real physical
world
but as evidence the classical general
relativity is breaking down at a certain
scale and it breaks down the big bang
near the singularities of black holes
Etc which is perfectly sensible because
it doesn't include quantum mechanics why
should you trust it anyway so to that
extent if you're saying well once we
understand quantum mechanics we will no
longer think that there are really
singularities in black holes then I'm
completely on board with that
the other aspect is the forgetting about
the singularities okay just thinking
about the general internal structure of
the black holes there's a and this is
hard to get into without pictures and
general relativity details Etc but in a
spherically symmetric black hole whether
it is uh totally vacuum as in the short
Shield solution or whether you include
matter in there Etc
um this these internal structure is
pretty straightforward everything
collapses and it will eventually over
time hit a singularity that's basically
it
if you look at the vacuum solutions for
spinning black holes or for electrically
charged black holes
they're wildly complicated inside you
get whole other regions of space and
universes and closed time-like curves
and a whole bunch of crazy nonsense
inside
almost everyone who is an expert in
general relativity believes that all
this crazy nonsense is an artifact of
finding a very very specific exact
solution that has no matter in it that
is purely vacuum so that has nothing to
do with Penrose Singularity theorems but
if all you're saying is that real world
black holes that are created from
collapsing matter will have a very
different internal structure
then the toy model Exact Solutions that
you can find for example in my general
relativity textbook then I completely
agree with that and people have done
numerical simulations to try to
understand what happens when real matter
collapses into black holes I'm not an
expert on the current state of the art
and what we've learned from those
numerical simulations but uh it won't be
the craziness that you get in the fully
what we call the analytically extended
Cur solution or Reisner Northern
solution it'll be something probably a
lot more believable
um none of this by the way matters for
anything that happens outside the black
holes outside the black holes we know
what is going on so it's interesting to
think about what happens inside but it's
not going to have an effect on you know
what ligo observes in gravitational
waves or anything like that Siddhartha
says your recent paper reality realism
says the abstract proposition the two
plus two equals four is not a reflection
of an independently existing truth this
was very surprising to me later the
paper says we are then left with a form
of if then ISM in which two statements
of the form if these axioms are accepted
this theorem can be proven but a typical
mathematical realist wants the
proposition ethereum to be real not
merely the conditional statement I
always thought Siddharth is continuing I
always thought of mathematical realism
as given a particular set of axioms
theorems and properties logically a
necessary necessarily construct
themselves by implication independent of
any physical reality such that anyone
starting from the axioms has to reach
the same conclusions perhaps a better
term is logical realism and Mathematics
in general is an exploration of this
logical realm that consists of all
possible axioms and their implications
somewhat like the library of Babel
that's Jose Luis Borges story that we've
talked about before
but it seems you have something
different in mind when you say not
merely the conditional statement do you
think logical realism is different and
side steps sidesteps the issues with
mathematical realism you mention in your
paper
well so this is referring to a paper
that I put online recently you can find
it by Googling reality realism or my
name or anything like that
um it was in response to the book
morality and Mathematics by Justin Clark
Doan so some of you might remember we
had Justin on the podcast to talk about
his book morality mathematics Justin is
a philosopher who
has he talks about the relationship
between morality and Mathematics in the
sense that what are our arguments for
realism or objectivity in both domains
and it's a complicated story that he
tells because it's not that they're
exactly the same or exactly different he
says they're more different they're more
similar than you might think but they're
still a little bit different and one of
the distinction C tries to draw is
between realism and objectivity
objectivity is when everyone would agree
something is true but realism is
something more than that realism is a
kind of existence uh mathematical
realism or more moral realism
so I will very quickly confess as I do
in the paper that I'm not an expert on
exactly these issues and one should be
an expert if one is going to comment on
them I only commented on them because I
was invited to do so by Justin in fact
in his book immorality and Mathematics
he starts the book with a quote by me
because I in the big picture I talk
about not being a moral realist but I am
a realist about the physical world and
he says that therefore Carol must be a
realist about mathematics because we use
mathematics to describe the physical
world and I'm not a realist about
mathematics actually I am a realist
about the physical world but not about
mathematics I do think that mathematics
tell helps us describe let's put it that
way the physical world in a very clear
way I use mathematics all the time but
I'm not a realist about it
so in the paper even though I'm
admittedly not a real not an expert on
the philosophy of mathematics or the
foundations of mathematics I tried to
describe what I think how it could
possibly be
that somebody could be uh realist about
the real world about the physical world
and not a realist about mathematics not
a platonist not a someone who believes
that mathematical structures and so
forth have real independent existences
so to answer siddhartha's question here
um you should really talk to a real
expert here but my belief is that the
standard to the extent that there is any
standard understanding in the philosophy
of mathematics which is probably not
completely true there's people who
disagree about all sorts of things
within that field but the idea is that
there is a difference between
objectivity and realism so in that field
the word realism means something more
than everyone would agree that these
theorems follow from these axioms you
can call that something but apparently
you should not call it realism logical
realism or mathematical realism or
anything like that it's something other
other than realism so the phrase if
thenism is used by these people to
denote The View that all theorems are
are logical reliable objective
conclusions deductions from their axioms
that is something less than what a
mathematical realist in the usual uh
construal means so a mathematical
realist doesn't just think that there
are axioms of number Theory from which
we can derive the fact that there is no
greatest prime number a mathematical
realist believes that there that there's
some truth to the statement that there
is no greatest prime number that goes
somehow Beyond any particular set of
axioms now this becomes very important
because the distinction becomes
important because when you dig deeply
into the mathematical foundation's
literature you realize that different
sets of axioms will generally have
different kinds of models different sets
of axioms do not uniquely imply what it
is you are talking about and in
particular the axioms that we use to
define the integers the number Theory
axioms piano arithmetic Etc
um have different models so there are
what are called non-standard models of
arithmetic there's not a unique model of
what we call arithmetic
um and you know they have different
properties these models and so the real
mathematical philosophers dig into what
that means and what it's good for and
again I'm not a super duper expert there
but
I agree that there is a sense in which
everyone agrees on the if then ISM
statements everyone should agree that
under the usual axioms of mathematics
the proof the theorems that you prove
using those axioms will follow from
those axioms but I don't attach realism
to that I think it's a different thing
so my my point in reality realism is
what I think is real is the physical
world that's what I think is reality so
that's that's the name reality realism
and what we call mathematics is a set of
ideas and structures that turns out to
be very very helpful in describing the
actual world and the experts in
mathematical philosophy disagree about
whether or not you need to be a
mathematical realist to consistently
describe the world using mathematics and
and things like that so even though I'm
not an expert I'm at least consoled by
the idea that the real experts disagree
with each other and you can check that
out so I do think this stuff is
important I don't want to downplay it I
just want to be very very honest about
not being an expert in it myself and
being an expert both implies sort of
knowing some substantive things but also
knowing the language the lingo and how
it's used
um so the lingo that is used by the
experts does not always map on in any
simple way to what we think the words
mean from our experience
Henry Jacobs says
is poetic nominalism a thing this would
be a nominalist who moves through the
world kind of like Poetic naturalist for
example she would believe the chairs are
not real but are still a valuable
concept and it's a good idea to act as
if they are real in many domains as an
applied mathematician I find myself
leaning towards something like this
since I use models all the time and
they're useful enough even though
they're not real I literally make them
up
I I didn't group these two questions
together but I put them together because
I do think that they're raising uh
similar related issues and important
issues and you know the more I think
about it I just maybe think that calling
things real or arguing about what is
real and what is not real is not helpful
that there are properties that things
have you know that we can rely on
certain deductions from the axioms like
we said and those are important
properties but debating over what's real
and what's not I don't know
um and this goes to not only math and
logic but as Henry brings up the idea of
different levels of description of
reality so nominalism
um is the point of view who's advocated
by Jody izuni who we had on the podcast
uh that what we talk about you know what
what for mathematics which is the usual
well I don't know if this is true I'm
I'm talking about things I'm not an
expert on uh nominalism goes back to
Occam uh William ivakum of Occam's razor
Fame and it emphasizes the idea that we
name things we give things names we give
things labels thus the name nominalism
and rather than thinking of things as
real we should think of them as useful
names okay so in particular mathematical
nominalists think that way about
mathematical structures integers things
like that so what Henry is suggesting is
that rather than being a poetic
naturalist which is the point of view
that I advocated in the big picture
where you say that there is a real world
it really exists but there's many ways
of talking about the world and if you
have a way of talking about the world
that accurately captures some real
behavior of the world then the
ingredients in that way of talking
perfectly well deserved to be called
real like tables and chairs for example
and Henry is saying how about instead of
calling them real we think of them like
anomalist would and we think of them as
useful names
you know
sure I kind of I don't want to uh I
don't I don't know is it is the short
answer you know again I'm not trying to
dismiss the question think of it as
uninteresting or anything like that but
there are very fine distinctions being
drawn here between things being real and
things being useful
in terms of describing the world and
living it and getting through it and I
just don't know whether those
distinctions matter in any important way
I wish I knew so again I'm not saying
that we shouldn't ask this question or
it's not interesting I think that I
don't know the best way to do it I'm not
sure if it matters whether we use words
like real or just use words like nominal
name useful things like that I need to
think about this more now that I'm
officially a philosopher because I'm a
faculty member in a philosophy
Department I can't get away with not
having opinions about these very
important issues
Eric Chen says in your conversation with
David Wallace you two seem to disagree
as to the best way of formulating the
past hypothesis you presented it roughly
as the early Universe was in a low
entropy macro state in the micro state
of the early Universe was some generic
microstate within this macrostate
whereas David framed it more as the
microsate of the early Universe was not
a conspiratorial one that contained lots
of delicate and crazy correlations
would you expand on this disagreement
what does a micro stay with many crazy
correlations actually mean and look like
and what's your current preferred way of
formulating the past hypothesis I you
know I feel like I'm I've listed a whole
bunch of questions in a row to which the
answer is I'm not sure or I'm not an
expert or I don't know but um I think
that I'm not sure how I formulated the
path hypothesis in the conversation with
David but I don't think I would have
done it the way that you quoted uh it's
very possible I did and I misspoke or I
changed my mind but the usual way to
think about it following David Albert's
book time and chance from the year 2000
which really put things in these terms
very clearly for the first time is to
separate out two different hypotheses
one the past hypothesis which roughly
says the early Universe has low entropy
uh and the second one which is just
called the postulate about statistics
which roughly says that within that low
entropy early State the universe isn't a
typical microstate not someone with
crazy correlations in some way and the
point of that second thing the point of
the Apostle about statistics is
as boltzmann knew very well you can
always go down in entropy right from any
initial starting point unless you're
literally at the minimum of entropy you
know that you can have specific
microstates whose future development
decreases entropy because you can just
imagine going toward that microstate
from the past and then time reversing it
okay so basically they just want to rule
out the possibility that not only is the
early Universe low entropy but also that
it is sneakily arranged in one of these
very very very rare microstates that
will still go down in entropy even
though it's already pretty low to start
with okay
that's not surprising I mean that's the
the thing to a physicist about this
discussion the fact that the early
Universe had low entropy is like a super
important fact that's really weird
because there's very much fewer low
entropy States than high entropy ones
that is calling out for some sort of
explanation
but the fact that the early universe is
does not have crazy correlations that's
a fact but that's not a very surprising
fact that's just what you would expect
so physicists worry less about this
particular statement now what the way
that David likes to put the past
hypothesis I don't know if it's the past
hypothesis or the possible statistics
that should really be the one being
talked about here but
he rather than making some statement
specifically about that early microstate
he wants to sort of use the future
evolution of the microstate to put
conditions on what can happen or what
does happen or how we should think about
what those initial conditions really are
I don't think it's that different I
think it's just a matter of convenience
honestly and and maybe it's cheating a
little bit to even think about future
correlations when or future behavior
when you're coming up with a
characterization of the early State it'd
be nicer to have a characterization of
the early state that only referred to
the early State itself not to its future
time Evolution also one of the reasons
why I'm not that into this question is
because I think that all of this
discussion
is kind of secretly assuming classical
mechanics Imagining the universe is kind
of like a box of gas that obeys the
rules of classical mechanics and uh we
can have sneaky correlations in it but
the world is not classical and David
Albert and David Wallace both know this
very well they write a lot about quantum
mechanics and I think that you can start
from a very Bland specific initial wave
function and get all the future
interesting Evolution out of it from in
my view or in David Wallace's branching
of the wave function but in someone
else's view maybe collapse of the wave
function under observations so I suspect
this particular argument is completely
irrelevant once you take quantum
mechanics into consideration there's
probably some specific rather than
saying the early universe is one of
various microstates that has the
following properties in quantum
mechanics we can just say it's this
microstate it's this particular Quantum
state of the early Universe and
Everything follows from that that's
exactly what Stephen Hawking and Jim
hartle tried to do in Quantum cosmology
for example I think ultimately that's
the way to go so the classical
conversation isn't that interesting to
me
schleier says I learned a lot from your
discussion with Molly Crockett on the
psychology of morality you and she
discussed how a focus on individual
Behavior can cause us to miss systemic
problems for me this brings to mind the
question of emergence do you think that
human civilization is a sufficiently
complex system that it can be seen to
have its own goals and motivations that
emerge from but do not exist at the
individual level
I think it's a very good question and we
can raise it in a related context with
AI okay rather than human civilization I
would say though for the human
civilization question the short answer
is no I mean the the question that I
would ask about a purported emergent
phenomenon is is positing this
particular feature of the higher level
immersion description giving us some
useful information that improves our
understanding of how the system behaves
so when you have you know what is a good
example when
um I'm hungry
I will go to the grocery store and I
will buy food and then we'll come back
and cook it and I don't know exactly
what I'm going to buy but just knowing
that I'm hungry and I want to eat
something and I don't have any food in
the house you can predict I will go to
the grocery store and buy food and bring
it back or go to a restaurant or
something like that in other words
there's a goal that I have right now
that and knowing that goal helps me
predict the future Evolution okay I
don't think that that's obviously true
about human civilization certainly
empirically individual parts of human
civilization have done weird things that
it is hard to account for by any uniform
unified goal at any one moment of time
different it is perfectly okay to speak
about countries Nations governments or
whatever as pursuing a policy with a
certain goal you know that's that's okay
but it's just like a shorthand for
saying the actual government is thought
making the following actions okay
that attribution of intentionality can
be useful I'm not denying that it is not
possibly useful but I don't necessarily
think it's the best way to talk about
human civilization you know Daniel
Dennett another former podcast guest
um gave what is you know the classic
discussion of this question of when
should we talk about systems as having
intentions he called it the intentional
stance when should we talk about the
system as having a goal having its own
desires or whatever and yeah guess what
it turns out to be a tricky question
um I don't so maybe at some level for
human civilizations that's a useful way
of thinking but I think generally it's
just anthropomorphizing something that
is a little bit different than a human
being
coffee addict says chat GPT the AI
program you can go in and uh and talk to
has been a Hot Topic as an application
of machine learning recently
additionally several image generation
tools have been introduced including
stable diffusion Dolly to Mid Journey
Etc I heard that the mechanism of these
inner image generation tools are based
on diffusion models which were
originally studied in non-equilibrium
thermodynamics do you find anything
interesting about the relationship
between machine learning and physics
such as the use of diffusion models in
image generation
before answering let me just say to
everyone listening out there if you
haven't played around I should have said
this before in the discussion with um
Rafael miliere or various other ones but
if you haven't played around with chat
GPT or dolly or mid-journey or one of
these uh image creation algorithms it's
very very worth playing around with them
both because and it's not that hard sign
up and you know you can get access and
then you can ask it questions you can
get into arguments with jet GPT uh very
clearly it's very very obviously
programmed to say that it is not
conscious so you can you can try to
convince it of some things when it'll
say you know certain if you ask it about
me like as I said in a like a few amas
ago it'll say very wrong things about me
personally but then you can correct it
and it will usually go oh okay thank you
for the correction not about whether
it's conscious so it is easy to do it is
both very very educational it's fun
um because you you
kind of are trying to think trying to
guess what it will say before it says it
it's very smart you know knows a lot
about the world Etc
um but also because they're going to be
everywhere these AI programs so it's a
case where even if you don't want to be
an early adopter it would be it would be
useful to you I I recommend to at least
get a feeling for how they work and what
they do anyway with all that in mind
coffee addict is asking a question about
the relationship between how these
models actually work and physics
and there is absolutely relationship and
I don't know a lot about it so I'm not
here to actually answer the question in
any detailed way but there is a lot of
physics there
um because what happens is
you know back in the old days as we
talked about with in previous uh
podcasts Gary Marcus Melanie Mitchell
Stuart Russell we've had a lot of
podcasts about artificial intelligence
the old-fashioned way was to try to
model the world explicitly in your AI
program that was called symbolic
approach to AI in the more recent
connectionist approach you don't presume
to be better at modeling than the
computer you you make the program be a
basically a blank slate to start and you
let it learn you let it try some random
things you tell it yes you did well no
you did badly and it learns very very
rapidly
so that's very very useful it's good you
can train the computer to beat the
world's best go players or chess players
uh to have conversations to make
beautiful images and so forth and all
that stuff but is it the best is it in
fact the most efficient way to learn and
you know in fact it's not just you build
a giant computer and you let it rip okay
there is a lot of work that goes into
figuring out the best way to help your
AI program learn you know the amount of
data out there it has to sift through is
very large you would like it to be a
little bit efficient right a little bit
thoughtful a little bit
um smart about how it gathers data puts
it together and and does its next thing
so
it is there's undoubtedly true that
thermodynamic or statistical mechanical
considerations come into this question
uh for one thing there are random
numbers there you can ask GPT or chat
GPT the same question twice so we can
use two slightly different answers or
maybe even very different answers and
basically you know it's this general
idea of exploring a really really large
space the space of possible answers that
chat tpd can give you in terms of
sentences strings of words is enormously
large much much larger than it will
actually ever do in some very weak sense
the problem that the program is trying
to address is how to pick out the right
string of words in the space of all
possible strings of Words which is just
a crazily large thing so
that's why diffusion appears in the name
um stable diffusion there's sort of a
different ways of attributing structure
through this giant space of possible
answers and using that structure
leveraging it for giving answers in a
reasonably efficient amount of time
um but that's it that's all I know I
mean that's a very superficial level of
understanding I know that it's really
important uh Johns Hopkins is is
launching a major initiative to hire
people in artificial intelligence across
the disciplines so we have people who
will be working in the physics of AI uh
the philosophy of AI you know history
biology and of course the computer
science and the engineering of AI also
um so there's a whole new field of the
physics of machine learning and
artificial intelligence that is
fascinating and important I don't know a
lot about it but I bet I will be
learning about it in the years to come
Jonathan bird oh finally we're back on
my home turf here Jonathan bird says why
is losing information to entropy
expected and accepted while information
lost in a black hole is treated as a
crisis in physics so it's not a crisis
in physics by the way it's a puzzle it's
a puzzle to work out that's that's the
bread and butter of physics that's all
we want we want puzzles how does
information or does information get out
of an evaporating black hole and the
answer to this question is very very
simple actually although it's an
important one it's just the difference
between what you might call fine-grained
information and core screened
information
fine-grained information like imagine
the world were perfectly classical okay
so you don't have to worry about the
subtleties of quantum mechanics the
world was really literally a bunch of
billiard balls bumping into each other
or interacting through some Force law
okay when you want to describe the air
in the room as we said you could do it
in principle by knowing everything about
every atom and molecule right every
position every velocity Etc you could
predict what happens next or you could
just know the course grained information
about temperature and density and
pressure and predict pretty well what's
going to happen so the fine-grained
information is that complete
specification of every position and
every velocity in the air in the room
the course grained information is just
the observable temperature pressure and
stuff like that so when you say
information is lost because entropy is
increasing
that's just because you're coarse
graining that's not a statement about
the fundamental laws of physics that's
just if you list a sequence of course
grained states that a system is in and
those states have increasing entropy and
that's all the information you have then
knowing the higher entropy States
knowing the states of the higher entropy
States gives you less information you
have lost information compared to
knowing the low entropy configuration
that it used to be in
whereas the underlying dynamics of the
billiard balls interacting with each
other is perfectly information
preserving right even though I
personally am course grading and
therefore losing information the world
is not losing information it's being
micro physically complete and reversible
that's what's supposed to be happening
in the black hole when the black hole
evaporates it's supposed to be obeying
the rules of quantum mechanics and at
the fine-grained level it shouldn't be
losing any information that's what we
think anyway some people disagree there
is a subtlety here that I will that will
bring up which is that
there's a very important part of quantum
mechanics where information is obviously
lost namely measurement
whether you want to think of it as
decoherence and branching as a many
worlds person would think of it as or
you just want to think of collapse of
the wave function as a Copenhagen person
would
um you have an unpredictability and
irreversibility and if all you know are
all you're told is to state after a
measurement or a branching you can't
reproduce what the state was before that
is an irreversible information losing
process so that's gonna you know when we
talk about black holes and Hawking
radiation and stuff like that uh black
holes get measured they interact with
the rest of the world they decohere so
the statement that the
um total Evolution should be information
conserving is a subtle one that you
better be careful about in fact I wrote
a paper about this
um with you know I was I was a co-author
on a paper let's put it that way a lot
of the work of course was done by my
collaborators this was with I'm going to
forget the whole list of people but ning
bao was the was the first author and the
title I think was something like
branches of the wave function with black
holes need not contain firewalls this
was supposed to be responding to the
idea of firewalls and we uh the point of
the paper was we took seriously the idea
of branching and decoherence Etc and
pointed out that where entanglement
lives depends on whether you're asking a
question about just one branch of the
wave function which you would ask if you
were making measurements or whether
you're asking questions about the global
wave function of the universe which no
one Observer can see so we pointed out
that there was a loophole in the
argument for firewalls that was put
forward by amps that we talked about
here on the podcast before
um so anyway that's just I'm just
mentioning that as a point to personal
interest that I think that people are a
little too quick and glib when they're
talking about unitary information
conserving evolution of black holes
there is something going on that loses
the information that we should keep in
mind whether it doesn't solve all the
problems keeping it in mind but it
should nevertheless be kept in mind
George Hampton says I just started
looking into Retro causality and the
transactional interpretation of quantum
mechanics and while it sounds
interesting I'm concerned that I might
be chasing a dead end idea what are your
thoughts on this concept and do you
think it is worth my time and energy to
dig more deeply into this well I will be
you know perfectly honest
I think it is not worth your time and
energy to dig more deeply into Retro
causality and the transactional
interpretation you know there are people
who are very very smart and very very
well informed who would completely
disagree with me so you don't need to
follow me just because I'm an expert
here it's a controversial question I am
a many worlds person I think that the
Schrodinger equation tells us how the
quantum State evolves I think that it is
kind of silly to imagine we need to
bring in influences from the future
interacting and affecting what we are
observing today it's certainly not
necessary given anything that we know
experimentally or theoretically about
quantum mechanics and I certainly don't
think it makes anything easier or
simpler to imagine that so I'm not going
to pay too much attention to it as
always I could be wrong so let the buyer
beware
says Einstein used a lot of thought
experiments when thinking about his new
physics these days thought experiments
are used a lot in Philosophy for example
when thinking about Consciousness
however I wonder whether thought
experiments have become less helpful in
physics at least when studying complex
systems they seem to have a limited role
but maybe it is different in say
cosmology or particle physics do you
have any thoughts on this
yeah I think that I think the thought
experiments are almost impossible to get
away without using I mean what do you
mean by a thought experiment you mean
some situation that you set up in your
mind for whatever reason it's too
complicated or too difficult to do it in
reality like what if I were riding a
light beam right okay so I can't do that
in reality but I can ask the what if
question and we're trying to probe The
Logical coherence of our ideas if you
believe this then this should follow in
some hypothetical situation that's
absolutely something that we use all the
time in modern physics we were just
talking about black holes and firewalls
the firewall
dilemma comes from thought experiments
if I were to dive into a black hole what
would I see as I cross the Horizon right
I can't actually do this it's just a
thought experiment now do they play as
an important role in complex systems I
think the answer is yes they will play a
very important role but maybe the
usefulness is less obvious because what
what thought experiments let us do
is probe the like I said The Logical
consistency and implications of our
theories in the case of complex systems
we don't have great theories right we
have some principles some hopes some
predictions some features that seem to
be Universal or at least very common but
we don't have a paradigm like we have
classical mechanics quantum mechanics
statistical mechanics relativity or
whatever right so it is there's less
call for pushing the implications of our
theoretical predictions when we don't
have as many theoretical predictions
okay so it's not the fault of thought
experiments it's the fault of our
current state of knowledge in this very
difficult field of um complex systems
Anthony Robo says the Academy Awards
what are your thoughts on the dodging or
the concept as a whole or on the
snubbery of the menu
I think it's outrageous that the menu
was snubbed at the Academy Awards
although okay to be fair no I don't
think it was outrageous I you know I
don't care that much about the Academy
Awards I I do think that the menu is one
of my favorite movies of the year
um I did not see anything like a
comprehensive list of movies this year I
certainly didn't even see most of the
best picture nominees so I cannot
possibly
legitimately complain about who got
nominated and who didn't but for me the
best movies of 2022 were at the menu
uh Glass Onion and of course everything
everywhere all at once which did win the
Academy Award I mean my personal rooting
interest there was that I've always been
both happy and somewhat amazed at how
we've we've managed to have all sorts of
impressive people here as guests on the
mindscape podcast and one one
qualitative qualitative measure of their
impressiveness is the number of prizes
won so we've had Nobel Prize winners
we've had MacArthur Prize winners
Pulitzer Prize winners breakthrough
Prize winners Etc
um Grammy winners Emmy winners we had
never had as far as I know an Academy
Award winner on the podcast but of
course I did interview the Daniels about
their movie everything everywhere all at
once and then they went on to win the
Academy Award so now I'm gonna try to
spread the word that the way to win
Awards to first appear on the mindscape
podcast and that will boost your case
um I love the menu you should also watch
that one sad that it didn't win as many
awards but not completely surprised
because
that movie was more or less made for me
Jennifer and I both agree like we were
watching that movie and I don't think
there's ever been a movie where as often
we like were elbowing each other and
going do you see what they just did
isn't that great and I also think for
those of you who haven't seen it um the
menu is
described as a satire of foodie culture
right and I think that's just missing
the point again on maybe like the Jane
Austen uh discussion
the the menu is way deeper than a satire
of foodie culture foodie culture is just
too soft and easy a Target okay the menu
is really an interrogation of artistry
and creativity and the relationship of
artists and creators to their audiences
and it's a much broader richer more
interesting vein to mind than just going
to fancy restaurants and making fun of
the dishes for being a little weird
they're both there they're both in the
movie but there's more to it than that
surface level
Eric Weber says I'm auditing a course on
philosophy of space-time and matter
which is excellent my question is on
simultaneity you say in the biggest
ideas of the universe that Proxima
Centauri is four light years from Earth
which corresponds to an eight-year span
of events that could be considered
simultaneous with a single event on
Earth that blows my mind I want to do
the math I have my graph paper out
space-time coordinates and light guns
ready to go but even after solving many
relativity problems in class I can't
seem to figure out where to start on
this can you nudge me in the right
direction
I think there's less math here than
meets the eye to be perfectly honest
um get out your graph paper
draw some x and t axes your space time
diagram right put the Earth right now
this very moment at the center x equals
zero T equals zero draw some light cones
at 45 degrees at x equals four light
years put a straight line going
vertically representing the world line
of Proxima Centauri okay and the point
is that in relativity
you can pick reference frames that
stretch in any horizontal seeming line
as long as it's not tilted more than 45
degrees on your piece of paper so I can
draw a line tilted at 44 degrees right
going through the earth going through
the center of your axes that would be
the reference frame constructed by
someone going through the Earth right
now moving close to the speed of light
and it would tilt so that it sort of
goes up and to the right and hits that
Proxima Centauri Line near T equals four
years because x equals four light years
corresponds to T equals four years and I
could also tilt it in the other
direction going down sloping downwards
so that it hits the Proxima Centauri
Line near T equals minus four years so
the only math is what is 4 minus minus
four and the answer is eight that's
where the eight comes from okay the
total amount of time spent by Proxima
Centauri which is four light years away
in the light cone
sorry I should say outside the light
cone of the Earth At One Moment In Time
it lasts eight years because it's four
light years away and it's just very very
simple math you don't have to work very
hard sorry about that I don't disappoint
you that there's not more math there but
that's all you need for this
qubit says you mentioned that in the
weak field limit which includes all of
our everyday life gravity fits well into
the framework of ordinary quantum
mechanics at the same time Roger Penrose
proposes the controversial idea that
every wave function collapse is caused
by gravitational effects how is there
even room for such an idea if the wheat
field limit has already been solved
without any problems well it's not
actually a contradiction I mean well
sorry it's not surprising but it is kind
of a contradiction because Penrose is
suggesting that ordinary quantum
mechanics is not right he's suggesting
that we modify ordinary quantum
mechanics so my statement is that
gravity in the wheat field limit like
you correctly say gravity fits in
perfectly well to the framework of
ordinary quantum mechanics I don't think
Penrose would disagree with that he's
just saying that I want to change
ordinary quantum mechanics in a way that
depends on gravity so that's an
alternative idea and we're too far away
from being able to test this to know
which idea is correct it is potentially
testable people have thought about
trying to test penrose's suggestion for
when wave functions collapse and
hopefully they will do it and I predict
that what they will see is that his
prediction is not correct
I I would be very very surprised if
gravity had anything to do with the
reasons why wave functions appear to
collapse
Josh Charles says in an emergent space
time is it possible that our definition
of locality is updated such that Bell's
theorem is no longer applicable could
spooky action at a distance only seem
distant because we don't yet fully
understand how space works
well yes and no I kind of want to say to
this
um there's sort of two aspects that are
worth mentioning one is that
[Music]
um
in an idea where space-time is emerging
even if it's just space that is emergent
the I certainly the notion of locality
is going to be a little bit less
fundamental than it is if you start with
space and time as fundamental
ingredients of your theory okay locality
is going to be an emergent approximation
like temperature and density in tables
and chairs it's not going to be part of
the fundamental architecture
so in principle there could be some
minor variations on things like Bell's
theorem okay although really Bell's
theorem has to just do with correlations
uh not necessarily there's there's no
statement in Belle's theorem that the
correlations change as a function of
distance right Bell's theorem is just a
statement about what correlations there
can be in a quantum theory versus in a
theory of classical correlations so I
don't expect any dramatic change in
Belle's theorem but the other thing to
say is that
I don't think that the quantum
mechanical any surprise that you are
feeling because of Bell's theorem
I don't think is a big deal I don't
think that Bell's theorem is a big deal
okay that's put me my own cards on the
table here I think that Bell's theorem
surprises you if you were really hoping
that the world is fundamentally
classical and that space and time or
fundamentally fundamental
um in many worlds the fundamental thing
is the Quantum state of the universe and
that is a vector in Hilbert space and
the whole idea of space is something
that pops out at the emergent level and
to me from that perspective the weird
thing is not that there is some kind of
locality he has predicted by belsteer
some violation of locality some kind of
non-locality predicted by Bell's theorem
the weird thing that demands explanation
is that there is any locality
since I don't start with space as a
fundamental ingredient of reality the
thing that requires explanation the clue
that should help guide us in developing
our theories is that locality is a
pretty good approximation in the world
the classical level it's an extremely
good approximation so I I think that we
don't know how space Works in any
complete way but I also think that if
you're really accepting of the
everettian point of view of reality uh
Bell's theorem is not some weird mystery
that we must solve to understand where
non-locality comes from the mystery is
why the world looks even a little bit
local
Nikita lozavoy says priority question
remember for those of you who are
newcomers here uh if you are a patreon
supporter you can ask questions and
since I can't answer all of them once in
your life you get to label a question of
priority question and I will do my best
to answer it so Nikita's priority
question is time travel related question
recently I listened to your solo podcast
about time travel and it's awesome but
I'm still mind-boggled about something
and thought you could help to clarify as
far as I know a clock on the
International Space Station is going
about
.007 seconds behind a synchronized clock
on Earth's surface for every six months
it's in orbit and that's through the
effects described by the special theory
of relativity what I don't understand is
why it's specifically the clock on ISS
that goes slower relative to the one on
earth and not vice versa well I think
that this is you know something you can
read about in various of my books from
eternity to here if you want the
non-equation version or there's some
more equations just a little bit more
equations and the biggest ideas in the
universe
but it's not really I personally don't
like saying that one clock moves more
slowly than another I think that I get
it I know why people say that but that's
only going to happen to clocks that are
separated from each other because
they're moving on different trajectories
to the universe so how do you know how
to compare them you would have to bounce
light back and forth or something like
that you'd have to agree on a protocol
for doing that but I know what they mean
in this case when you have a clock on a
spacecraft orbiting the Earth you can
sort of get a signal from it when it's
right above you and measure its time and
then wait for it to go around one orbit
get another signal so you can ask how
long has passed free to you on the space
station and then you can compare it to
how long has passed down there on Earth
and there will be a difference okay
point zero zero seven seconds I don't
know that sounds perfectly plausible to
me
but this is a combined feature of both
special relativity and general
relativity and again I'm not even sure
in this particular case which is more
important the space station is traveling
it's moving compared to the rest frame
down here on Earth but it's also in a
different gravitational field so there's
two effects and you have to include them
both in GPS for example this is why you
have to include general relativity in
your calculations but anyway the short
answer is that the trajectories are not
equivalent to each other you know you
see you're asking why is it one clock
that is objectively said to be moving
more slowly than the other one but
there's no symmetry between these two
situations one is in orbit around the
Earth and the other is forgetting about
the rotation of the earth because that's
very slow compared to the orbital period
of the space station
um so to all intents and purposes the
other one is sitting stationary on the
surface of the Earth so you have two
different trajectories in the universe
and I'd like to always recommend when
people are thinking about these time in
special relativity questions just ask
the analogous question for spatial
distances in ordinary physics I have two
points in space and I travel between
them on two different trajectories if
one is a straight line and the other is
a curved line no one is surprised that
one involves traveling a different
distance even though you leave at the
same point and you arrive at the same
point which one takes a longer distance
the one that is more curvy right the one
that is less straight the two curves are
not equivalent to each other so in this
case there are two objects a clock down
here on Earth and a clock on the space
station that to some approximation are
leaving from and returning to the same
points okay we can be careful about that
but what we mean by that but there are
ways to be careful about that and the
trajectories are very different so you
should not expect that the elapsed time
on these two trajectories is the same
both of them are kind of moving because
the Earth is rotating and one is deeper
in the gravitational field Etc so it's a
little bit trickier
but at the end of the day you will plug
into the equations you will figure out
what the elapsed time along that
trajectory is in much the same way that
you would figure out the elapsed
distance along some curve here on Earth
would be in this case the way that it
happens to work out is that the clock of
the International Space Station is going
to be a little bit behind the one here
on Earth but you could work out the
equations for yourself
Kent says what are your hopes for the
future of social media in the wake of
Twitter chaos many competitors are now
jockeying for position I'm intrigued by
the alternative decentralized Network
approach to social networks such as
Bluesky Jack dorsey's latest project or
are we all heading for the metaverse
I mean the metaverse is an interesting
thing if it just means virtual reality I
think that uh the folks from Facebook
who rebranded themselves meta are trying
to relabel things to their own advantage
and then makes perfect commercial sense
but the idea of you know a virtual space
which you can interact is much older
than that and actually I am pretty
bullish on the future of such virtual
spaces I predicted uh quite a while ago
that eventually we would all have our
own little virtual realities just like
we all have our own web pages we don't
all have our own web pages but we use
them all the time right there are
technological and social hurdles to
making them super duper common it's a
little bit more clunky right now to use
those spaces than to use regular web
pages but I think that that will happen
but anyway I think it's a separate
question from the social media question
I don't know what the future of social
media is really going to involve to be
very very honest I I think that Twitter
is in a slow decline
it's there's more noise on there they're
doing silly dumb things with verified
accounts and and letting Bad actors back
on the platform and flooding uh
timelines with tweets you don't want in
advertisements and overall it's a less
pleasant experience than it used to be
I'm slightly surprised no one has just
come out with a clone of Twitter like
honestly if you just made a clone of
Twitter with an edit button and didn't
mess with it that much
people would flock to it but the
Alternatives that are out there like
Mastodon and post and so forth they all
want to make improvements and the
improvements aren't always what people
want Mastodon is a good idea that it
it's just so clunky to get on it and to
use it and so forth so I don't know you
know I think that there is a feature of
social media that it works best when
there's a lot of people on it so that
means that the winner is not necessarily
going to be the best one it might just
be the one that for whatever reason most
people end up joining and therefore I
find it very difficult to know what that
will be there's not a lot of stickiness
right you know if you do get a lot of
people to join your social media Network
there's no reason why you can't just
kill off the old ones Myspace died right
so there's no reason that just because
Twitter exists now and is fairly popular
or Facebook exists now and is fairly
popular they will still be around 10
years from now not that hard to imagine
people switching
I I love the idea I don't understand a
lot about the Blue Sky project that Jack
Dorsey has
um it seems to be an idea where
individuals control their knowledge
their data their information and then
they can choose to share it as they wish
on different social media sites which if
that is it sounds great
um but you know there's people need to
make money people want to make money
anyway and you know I think this is what
Elon Musk doesn't understand about
Twitter the the value in Twitter is the
people tweeting on it and you can sell
those people to advertisers somehow he
thinks that the people tweeting on it
should be paying him for the right to
tweet it's like asking magazine
contributors to pay for the right to
publish in your magazine right that's
just not the way it works and if you
know he tries to make people pay for it
they're going to switch to go somewhere
else I don't know so in other words it's
my short answer but I am very open to
the landscape looking very very
different five or ten years from now
Michael Kramer says could you say
something about your choice of Desert
Island episodes of the podcast and then
he goes on as a longer question but he's
asking you know what are the episodes of
the podcast that personally had an
effect on me you know as in as a
principle
I kind of don't like to rank my favorite
podcast episodes I think it's kind of
unfair to all the guests like I very
much appreciate that all the guests who
have had on the podcast have taken their
valuable time to be on the podcast and
to talk and to share their thoughts with
a lot of people so I want to rank them
if you rank them then someone's gonna
end up last or someone's gonna end up
not being noticed I do have you know a
couple that
um I do think made a big impact on me in
different ways but I'll just mention one
because I used to mention all the time
and I haven't mentioned it I think in a
while which is Joe Walston talking about
urbanization this was a fairly early
podcast Joe Walston is a conservationist
and he tries to make the point that the
fact that there's an increasing
percentage of people who live in cities
in the world is really good in many ways
because the more people live in cities
the more the rest of the land of Earth
is left for nature in some sense and so
he says that we can have an equilibrium
with a very large population here on
Earth as long as we live densely as
human beings and we preserve the habitat
for the rest of the ecosystem outside it
doesn't mean that you ban people people
actually like living in cities so you
just make it Pleasant and and
possible for them to do so they
naturally do so the world is becoming
more and more urban and
um Joe's point was that in many ways
that's good that can be remarkably good
and and maybe if we get there fast
enough we can save a lot of species from
going extinct so that's one anyway that
I would bring up that is not an obvious
choice some of the obvious choices are
just kind of obvious and good
says in your most recent book the
biggest ideas in the universe space time
in motion I love the way you built up
Einstein's field equation from first
principles I assume these equations
don't yet include the cause module
constant I'm curious to understand the
conceptual leap needed to apply these
equations to the entire universe which
led to the introduction of the
cosmological constant so actually it's
it's really not like that there's no
conceptual leap needed to apply these
equations to the entire universe I mean
Einstein did it pretty quickly you know
he had the equations for from the start
in 1915 and by 1917 he was writing
papers about cosmology it's just a
matter of choosing a form for the
space-time metric that would apply to
the whole universe and likewise the
cosmological constant is absolutely part
of the field equations I wrote down it
is true that historically the way
Einstein invented the idea of the
cosmological constant was to say is
there a different term you could add to
the equations that somehow relates to
the curvature of space-time but he
recognized pretty soon and we certainly
recognize very well now that that term
is absolutely the same as adding an
energy density to empty space that's why
vacuum energy and cosmological constant
are completely equivalent and adding
energy density to empty space is just a
particular form of energy along with all
the other forms of energy so it was
already implicitly there as one of the
allowed things you could put in the
equation from the start you don't have
to add anything to it at all
Jameson Rader says how does causation
work in a block universe
I'm not sure uh uh what you're aiming at
here just because
I'm not sure how you think causation
Works normally or I guess I should even
say normally but in a non-block universe
there's one question which is how does
causation work right I mean that's an
important question for philosophers and
scientists to think about
um I I'm honestly not sure why living in
a block Universe would have any effect
on how you thought causation worked at
all the way that I think of causation as
as a higher level emerging phenomenon as
we've been talking about in the podcast
already if you look at the equations of
general relativity the standard model
particle physics or whatever there's no
term for causation in those equations
right causation is not a separate thing
causation is a way that we human beings
have of conceptualizing what happens
according to those equations even in
Newton's Laws right f equals m a force
equals mass times acceleration and force
in due to gravity is you know G M1 M2
over r squared so you can remove force
from the equation entirely you can just
relate the distance you are from a heavy
object to the acceleration due to
gravity that it causes on you the word
cause never appears in the framework so
to me the question is why is the concept
of causation useful to us at the higher
immersion level because it certainly is
I mean I'm actually writing a paper
about that and I've given a couple of
talks you can find them online if you
look hard enough about the relationship
between entropy and the arrow of time
and cause effect relationships it has to
do with the fact that you know the
information we have about the universe
changes over time as we've talked about
earlier because entropy is increasing
Etc and the way that it works is that
given the fact that entropy is
increasing there are facts about the
what happens at any one moment of time
that could be one way or the other given
previous moments not everything is
predictable both because of quantum
mechanics and because over ignorance
about the micro state of the universe
and which actually happens propagates
into the future and affects it but does
not propagate back into the past
it's ultimately because of the arrow of
time is the short answer but I think
that all the words I just said there
apply equally well for presentists as
well as for Block Universe people so I'm
not exactly sure what you're aiming hope
hope that answer reveals something that
you were looking for
Jason ricciardi says I'm currently
reviewing Bell states and their
importance in Quantum networking in my
Quantum Computing course so I was
astonished when I heard chat gpt's haiku
on Bell's theorem in episode 230. chat
TPT is also excellent at coding
activities do you think large language
models will reduce the need for software
developers in the workforce
well I think that
the most obvious prediction to make
which is not necessarily going to be
true but is you know the historically
sensible one to make is that the
introduction of new technologies will
not reduce the overall need for jobs
okay it has never happened new
technologies have gotten rid of certain
occupations but it they've also opened
up the need for new occupations so I
don't think that llms will reduce the
need for software developers but they
might radically change what the average
software developer actually does on a
day-to-day basis you can already for
those of you who don't know I've
actually been playing with this because
I am a very bad coder I mean back in my
day in my salad days as an undergraduate
I was you know very good at writing
computer programs some of the code that
I wrote is still used to analyze data in
the Villanova astronomy department but
that was a skill that completely
attribute I didn't use it that much once
I got onto theoretical physics and so
forth but I've always I've kept up a
little bit I learned a little bit of
python the very Basics and some plots
that I made have appeared in papers that
I've written Etc so I was fascinated by
the idea that you can now use
these AI programs to help you write code
and so in vs code which is
um the environment in which I play
around with these little python programs
you can have an extension which will
basically give you AI generated
suggestions about what's coming next and
that's not just you know I write a line
of code and it guesses what the next
line of code is you can write in the
comments
I would like to write a program that
plots you know the energy eigenvalues
for the simple harmonic oscillator as a
function of position and it will just
write the whole code for you and that's
kind of amazing and absolutely game
changing for people who write software
for a living but you still need people
because well let's put it this way this
the program the AI program makes a lot
of mistakes it doesn't always work okay
and maybe it will get better and better
but I think you will always want a human
being both posing the question about
what you want code what code you want to
be written and then checking that it's
actually doing what the human being
wanted it to do the large language
models are a tool right until they get
to the point where they're separately
conscious agents which we're not there
yet they're tools that you can use but
they're still going to be human beings
deciding how they should be used
Philip malinowski says this question
relates to a recent paper in nature
papers and patents are becoming less
disruptive over time in a nutshell does
the decrease in disruptiveness something
is It Something You observe and
especially what signs do you see do you
have an interpretation of why that might
be happening a couple of hypotheses that
come to my mind are maturing of science
there are fewer low-hanging fruits and
replication crisis fewer reliable
insights
so I don't have very informed opinions
about this paper it is a paper that I've
heard about but not read myself I've
seen what seemed to be very reasonable
sounding critiques of the title of the
paper Okay papers and patents are
becoming less disruptive over time the
idea as I understand it is that they
studied
um that they characterize a paper as
disruptive if it sort of was the
beginning of something like it the later
papers that cited it cited it but no
previous papers okay and it didn't cite
that many papers itself it started a
whole new thing so it was constantly
being cited by later papers I have no
idea whether that kind of methodology
accurately captures an intuitive notion
of disruptiveness but okay we do what we
can
I and I don't know I mean this seems
like an almost impossible question to
ask just because different subfields of
science are so very very different right
or even of engineering so
there seems to be a giant selection
effect here it's like asking
um you know who's gonna win the next
presidential election and but you ask
your friends in the yoga yoga studio
that you go to in Brooklyn versus you
ask your friends who are farmers in
Mississippi you know there's going to be
a giant selection effect depending on
who you're talking to it might not be a
reliable sample and I don't even know
how to make a reliable sample that
covers all of science when you're asking
is science becoming more or less
disruptive over time
it's absolutely true that individual
Fields do mature and low hanging fruit
does get picked and it becomes harder
and harder to make a truly disruptive
contribution
so therefore it's very possible that you
get a result like this just because you
were over sampling the mature parts of
science right and you don't even notice
that there's this new idea a new whole
area of science the physics of machine
learning like maybe you didn't include
that in your in your study I I just
don't know so I don't have a strong
opinion about the reliability of the
result
um my guess is that we have more and
more mature science as time goes on so
there are more and more fields in which
you don't overturn the entire apple cart
all at once but we also just have more
and more fields we have more more things
going on in science so my guess would be
that it could be simultaneously true
that there are more and more disruptive
things happening even though the
fraction of things happening that are
disruptive is going down that I have no
data on at all just a general feeling
nolita s says would you explain in your
own words how does looking at distant
galaxies allow us to look back in time
do we know the age of the photons by
their wavelengths only
well there's really two aspects of this
question the really easy one and the
extremely subtle one the very easy one
is whenever you look at anything you're
looking back in time because it takes
time for light to reach you uh the old
Mitch Hedberg joke is uh people show me
a photograph of themselves and say this
is what I looked like when I was younger
every photograph is what you looked like
when you were younger even though it's
just a little bit younger okay of course
when you look at astronomical objects
they are further away so it takes like
much longer to get to you moving at the
speed of light one light year per year
and therefore the effect is much more
noticeable than if you just take a
selfie which was still in the past but
not that long in the past the subtle
part of the question is how long did it
take what is the age of this thing that
you're looking at back there I remember
we just talked a little bit about in
special relativity you can't even say
what is simultaneous between here and
some distant place so how are we even
talking about the age of distant gal
galaxies and how do we know what that is
a big part of it is that even though
this doesn't always get emphasized in
discussions of special and general
relativity in cosmology in the universe
in which we live even though there's
relativity and you can use whatever
reference frame you want and different
observers will observe different things
nevertheless there is an obvious
standard reference frame to use one that
is at rest with respect to most of the
galaxies in the universe and the cosmic
migrate background radiation Etc there
is a cosmological rest frame so when we
talk about the age of the universe or
the age of distant galaxies we
implicitly mean in that Universal Cosmic
reference frame it's not the only one we
can use but it's extremely convenient
and so that's what we always end up
using
and then the question is how do you know
what the age of this distant thing is
well what is easy to measure relatively
is the redshift we know that when light
is given off by different physical
processes that involve atoms there are
Atomic Spectra that have very well-known
highly calibrated wavelengths in their
rest frame so when you see not just a
thermal black body Spectrum which is
sort of featureless and hard to
characterize we don't exactly know the
relation well if you knew exactly what
temperature a black body was and then
you observed it and redshifted you would
know what the redshift was but usually
you don't know exactly what that black
body is but if you see a spectral line
from a transition in an atom then you
know exactly what its wavelength was and
you can figure out it's redshift so that
tells you the amount by which the
universe has expanded since the light
was emitted that's not exactly the
distance Hubble explained to us that it
is related to the distance but if it's
very very far away then that
relationship might also be subtle so
that's why it was difficult for Hubble
to actually show that there was a linear
relationship between distance and
redshift because redshifts were easy to
measure but distances were hard so how
do we know the age of the photons well
it depends it depends on how far away
they are these days we think we have a
very accurate model of exactly how the
universe has expanded over time so we
can still try to directly measure the
the distance to things that's what we do
when we try to measure these
cosmological parameters like the Hubble
constant and the cosmological constant
and so forth but if you just want a
pretty good answer to the age of the
universe when a certain Galaxy Etc was
giving off its light all you need to
know is its redshift and the
cosmological model can be used to then
say and the universe was this old when
it gave off its its light that you're
seeing right now so that's generally how
we would end up doing it
Julian Howe says are there examples of
different kinds of infinity showing up
in physics and how would you
differentiate them well it depends on
what you mean by showing up in physics
uh there are physical models of the
universe physical theories that may
invoke different kinds of infinity at
least at the very simple way there are
two kinds of infinity that are relevant
the uh countable Infinity of the
integers and the uncountable infinity
which is bigger which is
um characteristic of the real numbers
and things like that now of course
mathematicians have been able to define
a whole bunch more Infinities that are
also uncountable but in different and
subtle ways as far as I know those
uncountable Infinities well I mean let
me let me think about this there
certainly are theories of quantum
mechanics and Quantum field Theory where
you're doing a path integral over all
possible Quantum paths Etc which would
in principle involve Infinities even
bigger than the cardinality of the real
numbers but
that's all theoretical right that's all
our construction of models that is not
something you can experimentally observe
in the world so in terms of the I was
saying that there are two issues here
one is our theories yes our theories
might very well involve different kinds
of Infinities the other is the world
does the world really involve different
kinds of Infinities there we don't know
there there's no super strong evidence
or theories you know as you know map
onto the world in certain ways under
certain circumstances and certain
approximation levels Etc but we don't
have any experiment that would actually
distinguish between a theory that was
only involving countable numbers versus
uh uncountable Continuum or something
like that so I don't know if we ever
would even be able to do that of course
some people have asked whether or not
secretly our use of infinity is
unnecessary whether or not the real
world is fundamentally discrete and
finite in a number of things that
happening in it but again if it is that
number of finite things that are
happening is so large that Infinity is a
pretty good approximation for our
purposes
relatedly we have the next question from
Tim Converse which is is our Quantum
Hilbert space infinite dimensional or
finite dimensional if this is not known
what considerations or arguments are in
favor of one side or the other
it's not known as the short answer to
that uh many physicists will say it's
infinite dimensional for the following
reason if you make a model of a very
very simple continuous classical system
and then you quantize it so you have a
simple harmonic oscillator or the
electromagnetic field or you know
anything that is continuous classically
and then you quantize it the quantum
Hilbert space will be infinite
dimensional for that so even just a
single particle moving in one dimension
has an infinite dimensional Hilbert
space as long as that Dimension that it
moves on is smooth okay so surely the
reasoning would go once you have a big
universe with many many particles you're
going to need an infinite dimensional
Hilbert space the problem is that we
don't know whether that model of the
universe as a smooth manifold is good
once you have quantum gravity Etc in
fact there are indications that it's not
the best indication is from black holes
we know that the entropy of a black hole
form from beckenstein and Hawking is a
finite number and it is proportional to
the area of the Event Horizon it's
roughly the area of the Horizon in plank
units divided by four depending on how
you put the two pies in there in the
plant units Etc and
maybe you can argue although this is a
little bit shakier than what that
entropy represents is entanglement
between inside the black hole and
outside the black hole and maybe you can
argue that the entropy of a black hole
is the maximum entropy that a system of
that size can have which means there's a
max amount of entanglement that you can
have and that maximum amount is still
finite if the black hole entropy is
finite and therefore the actual Hilbert
space of the quantum system that you're
calling the black hole would also be
finite and even though that only applies
to black holes strictly it implies an
upper limit for any region of space
because a black hole is the most entropy
you can fit into that region of space so
I actually wrote a short paper arguing
this with ning Bao and ashmeet Singh
saying the Hilbert space of quantum
gravity is locally finite dimensional it
was just one of these little essay
contest things it's not a major research
paper because I think a lot of people
already believe that this is true but
for the purposes of the essay we wanted
to Marshal all the evidence in one place
so people could sit down and think about
it because it's really not known all you
can say by the way is locally finite
dimensional in any one region of space
all you need is a finite dimensional
helper space to describe what's going on
are there an infinite number of regions
of space something we don't actually
know so for many reasons we don't know
about the hilber space of the whole
universe I think it's kind of the kind
of thing we should care about a lot but
that's that's just me
Nicholas vocrat says in the everettian
Multiverse accepting that some universes
are those in which very rare things
happen coffee cups phasing through
tables oxygen molecules collecting them
inside of the room Etc are some
universes inherently more likely for any
other reason than chance to be those in
which very rare occurrences occur but
another way could the fact that
something ultra rare happen in the
universe mean that that specific
universe is more likely to be one in
which such things happen
of course we don't know the final super
duper answer to this question because we
don't know all laws of physics but in
our current understanding of many worlds
and and how quantum mechanics works the
answer is no so just to make it very
very clear Nicholas is asking if you
tend to be in one of those rare branches
of the Multiverse in which unlikely
things are seen to happen does that
imply that unlikely things will continue
to happen and the answer is absolutely
no they're completely independent from
each other uh that's and this is
important because I think that one of
the reasons why people kind of struggle
with believing or giving a large
Credence to many worlds is they
instantly home in on the weird unlikely
worlds where unlikely things happen and
they're made uncomfortable by that it's
very much like people who didn't like
boltzmann back in the 1800s saying that
entropy just usually probably increases
and they're like every time I've seen it
it always increases
that's because the words likely and
probably are used in a very very
dramatic sense here the probability that
a bunch of very unlikely things happen
in everettian Multiverse is just really
really tiny just like it is an ordinary
quantum mechanics so focusing on those
rare unlikely branches of the wave
function gives you a bad impression of
what the average Multiverse is really
like and there's no reason to think in
anything we currently know about physics
that if you happen to be in a branch of
the Multiverse where a measurement came
out in one of the very very unlikely
outcomes that would continue to happen
for other measurements or other
branchings of the wave function
Anonymous says I want to be a Bayesian
and I feel inadequate unless I can
justify my beliefs with priors and
evidence when I can't find a working
prior I panicked I don't think you are
as obsessed with retconning a prior that
fits your conclusions I think you're
satisfied when you have a frequentist or
other pragmatic justification for your
conclusions should we be okay with
beliefs when we can't come up with a
Bayesian justification for them an
example of a non-bayesian argument that
you make is the probability of the data
of a needlessly big universe given weird
hypotheses like no low entropy past is
small or cognitively unstable therefore
this weird hypothesis is false
so I'm not I'm not sure that I quite
think you're using certain Bayesian
terminology correctly here it might be
that I'm this misunderstanding here but
you know Bayes theorem says that you
have a prior Credence or probability
that you're giving to various
propositions and then it tells you how
to update your credences when new
evidence or information comes in that's
all that happens the idea of Bayesian
epistemology is that that's how
knowledge works that we start with a
whole bunch of credences for different
propositions then we update them when we
get new information coming in if only we
actually did that that would be great of
course the reality is a little bit
Messier but
it so what if you know nothing if he was
just starting out and you have a
proposition that you know I'm going to
flip a coin and it's going to come up
heads or tails and and my friends tell
me it's a fair coin I have a prior
probability uh before I collected the
data before I actually collect uh flip
the coin and see what happened I have a
prior that it will be 50 50 heads or
tails but then when I flip the coin and
I gather some data if I flip it 100
times in a row in its heads every time
uh my prior is going to change right I'm
going to update that and guess what it
is no longer a prior it is a posterior
it is a probability that you are
associating with a certain proposition
but it's not your prior anymore the
prior is what you have before you've
collected any data okay it's not a
general word we use for all of our
beliefs almost all of our beliefs have
already been updated by a whole bunch of
data that we have collected okay and the
pros and cons of Bayesian reasoning are
almost all in the choice of a prior
people who are probation will say look
as long as your priors aren't completely
crazy if you collect enough data the
priors cease to matter if you had a
prior I think I'm 99 sure that this coin
is not a Fair coin and you're going to
flip it and it's gonna be heads every
time then you just collect the data you
just flip the coin over and over again
and you see one way or the other now in
practice that can be hard sometimes so
we are left with large uncertainties
that's okay but the promise of Bayesian
reasoning is that data overwhelms your
prior ultimately and therefore there is
no algorithmic way of choosing what your
prior should be it's a little bit fuzzy
to say you know when things are priors
and when things are posteriors because
we all have certain inclinations
intuitions pictures of the world and
that's perfectly okay but as a good
Bayesian you shouldn't be too worried
about picking your priors you should be
mostly worried about updating those
priors when data comes in when
information comes in and so nevertheless
to answer you there's a sort of hidden
question there at the end where you say
that when I talk about randomly
fluctuating universes and their
cognitive instability on being
non-bayesian I don't think I am being on
bayesium I'm making an argument for
giving a very very very tiny prior to
universes in which
we are randomly fluctuated out of the
chaos and all of our memories are
completely unreliable but I still am
very much working with an evasion
Paradigm there
Nick B says the commodification of brain
data which is an idea that appeared in
episode 229 with Nita Farah farahani is
perhaps the most terrifying phrase I've
heard on any of your podcasts unlike
many of the doomy scenarios that you
have discussed over the years this feels
urgent and unfortunately inevitable has
greater abilities to read brains develop
can you see a way for us to access the
technologies that are useful without
corporations mediating the experience in
an intrusive way well I am kind of on
your side that this is very terrifying
but it's gonna creep up it's not like
the corporations are gonna invade our
houses and attach electrodes to our
brains and scan them they're gonna offer
us the chance to purchase brains gaming
electrodes and we are going to buy them
and then we're going to send them our
data because it is slightly more
convenient this already happens right
this happens with credit cards it
happens with social media it happens
when we buy things online we are being
watched it's not quite 1984 level
watching because for what it's worth I
mean if this is some kind of comfort
here the corporations don't care about
you as an individual that much right
it's not like some person in the room is
tracking your purchases the computer
knows what your purchases is but the
corporation cares about the holes
statistical distribution of purchases
Etc but you know I think that
empirically we human beings are pretty
willing to sign over our privacy for a
small increase in convenience and so
we've been doing it already with all
those other examples so when it comes to
uh buying headphones that will let
corporations read our electromagnetic
activity in our brains yeah we're gonna
do that we're gonna give it away for
what it's worth
I think we have to rely on government
interference here if we want to be saved
from the worst abuses of things like
that I don't think that there is much
incentive on the side of the
corporations to not scan our brains and
use all of the data they don't gain
anything by not doing that so there will
be a race to do that uh and as Nita
farahani was trying to do we need
legislation that prohibits that or at
least we need you know some principles
even if you don't have detailed
legislation you want to establish some
legal principles that will let people
have countermeasures whether it's suing
or whatever when they think that their
private brain data have been abused I
suspect I'm not an expert here but my my
guess my prior is that there will be
some terrible cases of abuse and it will
be interesting to see whether or not
people actually react against it or
whether we decide collectively Lee that
it's okay that our brain data's privacy
is not that important to us as long as
we make it easier to uh play video games
without using our hands that I don't
know but I don't see lots of reasons to
be optimistic about it so that's why I
think that I think that that podcast is
very important and you know it's it's
talks about things in a much more down
to earth and specific way than uh you
know we've talked about before and it is
something that is potentially pretty
worrying
Derek Bain says what do you think of
Baltimore so far be nice it's my
hometown I really like Baltimore you
know the uh baltimoreans have a great
attitude in many ways uh it is certainly
and this is very subjective but I've
lived in you know a bunch of suburbs and
also a bunch of big cities
people in Baltimore are the nicest
people that I've ever met like you walk
into restaurants or whatever you just do
things in the city and people are just
really nice to each other in ways that I
maybe should have expected but maybe you
know living in bigger cities uh has has
spoiled me a little bit
um and and they have a little bit of
self-deprecation there uh you know
there's a a motto that was invented by
someone that has become very popular on
bumper stickers Etc which says uh
Baltimore actually I like it Baltimore
is not one of the uh you know famously
sexy and vibrant cities in the United
States you know if you if you're a
foreigner you don't live in the United
States you think about like oh what are
the big fun cities to go to in the U.S
you might say New York La San Francisco
uh who knows Austin I don't know these
days but uh Baltimore is like a solid
east coast city and I think that it
actually goes it it slides under the
radar I guess is what I would say as I
said earlier in the podcast it's big
enough there's a lot going on there's
far more going on than I can ever
actually experience uh the beautiful
parts of it are beautiful I happen to be
lucky enough to live right near campus
which is one of the beautiful Parts the
campus of Johns Hopkins so that's very
fortunate uh the restaurant team which
is very important to me is great there's
a lot of music and theater and not an
inconsiderable bonus it is on the Acela
Corridor so they can hop on the train
and go to Washington DC or Philadelphia
or New York or Boston and I've already
been doing that and that's a wonderful
thing of course it is in many ways there
are there are issues in Baltimore it's
not an especially wealthy City
there are uh there's poverty there's
homelessness like any other big city
the roads have potholes in them you know
that there's the Maryland and Baltimore
governments historically have not been
the most effective at getting things
done for the citizens Etc so there's
plenty to complain about I don't know if
there's more to complain about per
capita than in other big cities or
anything like that but roughly speaking
yes I like it very much uh you know you
can afford a nice house in Baltimore
that you couldn't afford in Los Angeles
um and academically and intellectually
Hopkins has been amazing so so far so
good for me as far as Baltimore is
concerned
Dan O'Neill says as an author what
qualities do you value in an editor a
literary agent a publicist
these are great questions and it's going
to defend a lot I mean I can give you a
little bit of my own feelings but it's
going to put a lot on what kind of
author you are what your audience is
what your writing style is ETC you know
these days there's a feeling that
editors I'm not even sure when to say
the word editor and when to say the word
publisher you know you so let's back up
a little bit let's imagine you want to
write a trade book
I did by the way if anyone's interested
do a one of the holiday special podcasts
short solo podcasts on writing trade
books and the process of it so you
should check that out if you want
um but you need an agent if you want to
write what we call a trade book or a
popular book you know I think a lot of
academics make this mistake because if
you're a professor of something you can
probably get your book published now if
if you're already a professor getting
your book published is not the big
hurdle because you're a professor and
you can go to an academic press right
you can go to Harvard University press
president University press whatever they
are not primarily devoted to trying to
make best sellers they like it when they
make best sellers but they really want
to write uh you know publish books that
are sort of academically respectable and
that's not to say they will publish any
old thing but if you're already a
professor probably you're competent
enough to write something that is
respectable and you can get it published
that doesn't mean people are going to
buy buy it if you want to publish with a
commercial press they're going to be
much better getting people to buy your
book and they're also not going to
listen to you unless you have an agent
so if you actually want to write a book
that people will buy a substantial
number of people will buy your first
step is always to get an agent and if
you have a book idea and you sort of
pitch it to random Publishers to random
house or whatever they're just going to
ignore you they don't pay attention to
you but if you pitch it to agents they
will pay attention to you because that
is their job their job is to filter
through all the pitches for trade books
and decide which ones are promising and
by the way they sometimes make mistakes
I pitched many many agents before one
would accept me okay uh and a good Agent
is one who will try to get what you want
right to try to fight for you
um they're your advocate in this whole
process and then you have the Publishing
Company where there's a person at the
Publishing Company
um who will be your editor there so
that's your editor working for a
publisher that's that's why I always
hesitate between the words editor and
publisher you can also hire an editor
which is a separate thing you personally
can pay for someone to edit your
manuscript because a lot of people who
are called editors working for
publishing houses are more about
acquiring books than about actually
editing them my own editor Stephen
morrow at Dutton who has been my editor
for all of my books he actually edits
the books and he we absolutely
collaborate on shaping a book into
something good so I got very very lucky
there so what you look for there in an
editor is someone who will edit who
cares about the book ideally someone who
will edit in a way that you are
compatible with but it's hard to know
until you've gone through the process
but you can get an idea just by talking
to them as far as publicists are
concerned you know if you publish your
book with a major publishing house they
will have publicists on staff so I don't
have a publicist other than you know
what the Publishing House does and I've
been pretty lucky I think although it's
very much a crap dude is my impression
you know as a podcaster I get pitched a
lot of people do appear on the podcast
by publicists working for book companies
right for Publishers and I think that
the there's certainly a mode of quote
unquote being a publicist which just
means whenever you have a book coming
out you send out a form letter to all
the podcasters and all the magazines in
the world saying you know do you want to
talk to my client and it's not a very
high effort but it's also not very
effective a good publicist will know
that there's certain venues that match
your book and develop personal
relationships with the people at those
venues and work to make sure that the
right authors are connected with the
right publicity venues again hard to
know ahead of time whether that's true
but you know any major grown-up
publishing house will at least strive to
do that so it's a lot of a black box
because you have to sign a contract Etc
before you know whether you know what it
really will be like to work with your
editor and your publicist and things
like that so you you can talk to other
people who've already written books but
um still you're you're going into the
dark a little bit then you see how it
how it works
Nicholas weiberg says if Dark Matter
could only interact gravitationally even
with itself would we still still expect
it to lump together if so is this effect
of general relativity or would it also
happen in Newtonian gravity
you do expect Dark Matter to lump
together but not as much as ordinary
matter and the reason is that in order
to lump together you know you have a
bunch of particles that are almost
perfectly smoothly distributed but not
exactly smoothly distributed what's
going to happen well gravitationally
it's going to pull together particles in
those regions that are over dense and it
will
clean out clear out the regions that are
a little bit underdense but then you
know the particles start moving toward
the center of the overdense region and
because they don't interact other than
gravitationally they just zoom right on
by each other
so you might think that to some very
very good approximation you don't really
love together because they don't stick
they don't hit each other and dissipate
like ordinary matter does real real
atoms can bump into each other lose
energy by emitting photons and therefore
stick together or at least stay in the
same region of space Dark Matter can't
do that it's collisionless it just
slides right through however there is a
more subtle effect which is that a whole
bunch of particles even if they're just
gravitationally interacting can come
together and lose energy collectively by
spitting out a few particles right so
you have a million particles and mostly
they condense into a dense region by by
conserving energy by spitting out some
high energy uh individual particles so
that most of the particles are lumping
together that is not as efficient a
process as literally bumping into each
other and radiating in terms of losing
energy that's why Galactic Halos of Dark
Matter are bigger and puffier than the
condensed disc made of ordinary matter
right if you think about what we know
about the structure of galaxies the
picture you take of a galaxy with all
the stars and the spiral arms Etc is
embedded in a bigger puffier Dark Matter
Halo which is exactly what you would
expect if the dark matter is
collisionless so you know it's again one
of the reasons why the vast vast
majority of working cosmologists believe
in dark matter because the universe
looks like it would look if dark matter
really did exist and has nothing to do
by the way with general relativity it
would be just as true in Newtonian
gravity
Joshua hillerup says in principle could
a living being like a cat or a physicist
in some sort of well-designed container
that has things like independent oxygen
supply be put into superposition for an
appreciable period of time or is there a
hard limit to what or how long could
something be in superposition
there's a tricky question because it
depends on what you feel about the
foundations of quantum mechanics so as
usual I will give you the answer for an
everedian uh version of quantum
mechanics but if you believe in
objective collapse of the wave function
you will get a completely different
answer here so for Everett it's
trivially easy to put something into
superposition for an appreciable period
of time there are literally a huge
number of universes in superposition and
they are very very different some of
them are very very different I mean many
of them are very close and very similar
to each other but many of them are
completely different from each other may
be what you mean by the question is
could you put two things into
superposition on a single branch of the
wave function and the reason why that's
a difficult thing to answer is what do
you mean by a single branch of the wave
function to me the most useful meaning
to that is to imagine that we have or at
least the most intuitively
graspable meaning to that is to imagine
that we have a clear distinction between
system and environment right that's the
The crucial setup that we need to
explain D coherence as I talk about in
something deeply hidden and elsewhere
what happens is if you have a
macroscopic system like a cat or a
physicist uh it's interacting with the
rest of the world it's interacting with
all the photons all the air molecules
Etc and we don't keep track of exactly
everything that is happening in that
rest of the world so we lump it together
and call it the environment and my
definition of branching of the wave
function is when the system becomes
decoherent by becoming entangled with
the environment that's when the universe
branches in that case you cannot put a
cat or physicist into a superposition on
a single branch of the wave function
because they keep bumping into the
environment around them even if you put
them in vacuum they're going to radiate
right they're going to give off infrared
radiation because they have a certain
warmth that's why quantum computers etc
have to be cooled down to close to
absolute zero to prevent them from
interacting with all the thermal
bathophotons everywhere around them so
if you have a living being
try to put it in a superposition of
being in two different physical spatial
locations for example it will instantly
radiate in different ways depending on
whether it's in one spatial location or
another therefore it will Branch
therefore on a single Branch you do not
have a superposition anymore you
effectively have a collapse of the wave
function onto those two different
branches so it depends on what you mean
by superposition that this actually goes
back to what I said earlier about the
paper that we wrote on branches of the
wave function not containing firewalls
where is their entanglement where is
their superposition depends on whether
you're asking about the whole wave
function of the universe or just a
single Branch thereof
Matthew Cushman says the boltzmann brain
Paradox and the simulation argument
seemed to me to have a similar structure
under some reasonableish assumptions
most observers with our experiences are
ontologically abnormal do you think they
are similar and pose similar challenges
and have similar resolutions there's
definitely a similarity there in fact in
the philosophy literature both boltzmann
brain scenario and the simulation
argument would be classified under
skeptical scenarios not that you should
be skeptical of them but they are
scenarios in which our immediate
impression of what the world is like is
dramatically off right dramatically
wrong for some reason in one case
because we randomly fluctuated into
existence and all of our opinions
randomly fluctuated and another because
we're kind of being tricked by the
existence of a simulator layer that is
giving us the impressions of the world
around us but the details of these two
skeptical arguments are very very
different for one thing the boltzman
brain scenario is way better defined
we know exactly what the probabilities
of various things happening are because
it's a by construction the Wilson brain
scenario is thermal fluctuations in an
eternally existing physical
configuration we know how to
characterize those things quantitatively
so we know exactly what to predict what
to expect
Etc whereas the simulation argument is
entirely ill-defined we don't know what
the simulators can do we don't know what
they're interested in doing we don't
know what the probabilities are of
different things happening Etc so I
think that there are both similarities
there and differences and it's it's
interesting to think about them of
course none of this is new it goes back
to brain in the vat uh thought
experiments or Renee Descartes imagining
that he was just being dreaming because
he was being tricked by a mischievous
demon okay that was fooling him so the
idea of skeptical scenarios
um has a very long philosophical
pedigree
Preston just I don't know if it's
Justice or usage uh says keeping in mind
that you identify to some extent as a
kantian constructivist I have a
philosophical question about the
relationship between normative ethics
and meta ethics would you agree or
disagree with the claim that in order to
do normative ethics responsibly or to
make normative odd claims about what one
should do that we must first not take
for granted meta questions about
normative ought claims and instead we
need more background questions about the
status of moral claims themselves which
produces a stronger meta-ethical
Foundation prior to even making claims
of what one ought or ought not to do if
we're even if we're relying on our
intuition as our starting point in the
form of weak premises per se is there a
more concrete way to do that responsibly
well I think that there are details here
that matter for one thing I'm not a
contian constructivist I'm a human
constructivist I talk about the
distinction between those two ideas a
little bit in the big picture
constructivists think that morality or
moral rules are not just located out
there in the world they are constructed
by us human beings the difference
between a kantian and a human version of
them is the kantine will say and there
is one uniquely right way to do that
there's a correct rational way to
construct our moral rules the human will
say different people are going to
construct different moral rules and we
can't say that any one of them is right
or wrong you know we talk to each other
we can try to persuade each other maybe
we're we'll argue that someone else is
being internally inconsistent Etc but we
can't just say objectively you're wrong
about your moral rules that you've
constructed so I'm on The Human Side
there as far as your actual question is
concerned
I had mixed feelings I would say I mean
I get so I would rephrase it as this so
I'll answer the rephrased question
because if I misunderstand it then I
don't want you to wonder why I'm
answering a different question uh we
have ethical rules right you know don't
kick puppies for no good reason that's
an ethical Rule and then we have
meta-ethical rules which are the reasons
why we accept or construct certain
ethical rules maybe because so
meta-ethical standards are like I'm a
moral realist I can find uh moral truths
out there in the world or I'm a
constructivist or you know I'm a
utilitarian or whatever
um but the reason I shouldn't say
utilitarian that doesn't count
utilitarian is ethical not meta-ethical
but if I have some reason why I'm
utilitarian that would be the
meta-ethical stance I think I don't want
to be too harsh I think that it's
actually quite similar to physics in a
different case there's obviously
differences because there is an
objective right or wrong to the
predictions you make as a physicist in a
way that there's not with the uh ethical
rules but I think that as a physicist
you know if I say that I have a rule for
why for when I put my cup of coffee on
the table it does not fall through
someone might say well okay what is your
justification for that in terms of the
quantum field Theory and the Pali
Exclusion Principle and the composition
of the table and the cup right do I I
think I would argue that the
relationship between ethical rules and
meta-ethical rules is kind of like the
relationship between this uh everyday
full physics idea that the coffee cup is
not going to fall through the table and
its underlying micro foundations namely
it's nice when you have the underlying
micro foundations
you can get through the day pretty well
without them so even if two people
disagree pretty severely on their
meta-ethical principles but their
ethical principles match pretty well I'm
happy to get along with such a person I
might disagree with their foundational
intuitions about why they're doing
things in a certain way but I'm going to
say that they're doing the right things
that's more important to me
Justin Wolcott says would I be wrong to
say that the odds aliens have discovered
how to travel faster than light are the
same as aliens having discovered how to
perform magic like like witchcraft not
just like illusions
I yeah I think that I think that that's
wrong but I think that I mean it depends
on what you mean by wrong uh this is a
question that we should think about as
good bayesians what is the probability
the Credence we have that aliens would
be able to discover that we can travel
faster than light what is the
probability that they could discover how
to truly do magic okay those
probabilities are very small so in that
sense they're smaller than Epsilon where
Epsilon is point zero one percent or
something like that okay
if you want to just lump together all
credences smaller than Epsilon and call
them the same then it's the same
there are degrees of small numbers right
if one number is 10 to the minus 5 and
the other is 10 to the minus 10 then the
10 to the minus 10 is smaller than 10 to
the minus 5 by a factor of 10 to the
minus five so I think that the ability
to do magic is way less likely than the
ability to travel faster than life even
if the ability to travel faster than
light is still super duper unlikely and
what I mean by that the reason why I
think that is because I can imagine
small modifications of the known laws of
physics that would let you travel faster
than light I don't think that those
modifications are true I don't think you
actually can I think that they're very
unlikely but it's not difficult to
imagine slightly different laws of
physics that would allow it whereas with
just doing magic I don't know how to
modify the laws of physics in a simple
way to make that permissible
Jacob asmuth says my girlfriend is
really into poetry and really enjoys
both reading and writing it do you have
any favorite poetry books poets or poems
thanks
Jacob it's okay to admit that you like
poetry you don't have to blame your
girlfriend for this question everyone
should like poetry a little bit you know
my own uh relationship with poetry is
very much like my relationship with
classical music which is that I really
do enjoy it but I am not in any sense an
expert knowledgeable or do I spend a lot
of time engaging with it I feel slightly
bad about that you know I think that
engaging with good poetry requires a bit
of effort you know you have to like put
in some time into reading and reading
very carefully and it's just hard to
find that time these days man there's
other things pressing on one's attention
so but I do like it you know when I get
a chance to read poetry books Etc
there's you know poetry is very
different so you can
um it's almost hard to say I like poetry
there's certain poets that just don't do
it for me at all and and others I quite
enjoy you know many of the classics I
enjoy Joy like Dante or Homer uh make
for amazingly good audio books because
they were I mean Homer anyway it was
originally
um oral tradition poetry right so if
you're going to drive across the country
it's hard to do better than listening to
a good audiobook of The Iliad or the
Odyssey uh The Inferno or Dante was not
meant to be read out loud but it really
does work very very well uh being read
out loud of course I I read I listen to
a translation not the Original Italian
among more modern poets you know I enjoy
a crazy
uh
incoherent incoherent yeah uh selection
to people from James Merrill is someone
I really like which is a little bit
weird
um Adrian Rich Wendy cope who writes
these silly little fun poems uh John
Ashbury uh slightly older E.E Cummings
uh Yates of course is just super amazing
Walt Whitman you know I'm not I'm not
gonna
claim any super expertise about who the
great poets are but there are people who
I absolutely do enjoy reading yes
P Walder says in the PostScript of how
physics makes us free Jinan Ismail
encourages the reader to consider
themselves as a complex system that has
arisen through the process of natural
selection and as such the associated
micro scale structure is arranged to
support the emerging complex system does
this imply a downward causation process
where the natural selection process
operating at the level of a complex
system causes the appropriate micro
scale structure to arise so I think that
questions about downward causation are
tricky and I shouldn't dismiss them but
in this case I'm just going to dismiss
them I think that roughly speaking the
answer is no I think that questions of
downward causation will depend a lot on
what you're taking the lower microscopic
level to be if you're taking it to be
literally atoms and molecules and
Quantum fields and so forth the core
Theory then there's no downward
causation going on because if I ask what
an individual electron does the
information I need to answer that
question is literally what is exactly
the local environment of that electron
what is the value of the electromagnetic
field of other fermionic fields that are
nearby that is all I need to know I do
not need to know anything about the
larger context and which is it embedded
I don't need to know if it's in a rock
or a brain or Interstellar space or
whatever I need to know the value of the
other Quantum fields at exactly that
location so there's no room for downward
causation to do anything that doesn't
mean it's not helpful to we human beings
okay if I know that a certain thing is
you know a snowflake then that will
instantly give me some information about
the microscopic structure of the water
molecules that are going into making up
that snowflake that doesn't mean that
the water molecules themselves care
about the fact that they are in a
snowflake but it helps me understand it
a little bit I think it's very different
if you're talking about the relationship
between let's say a human being and
Society so when human beings are the
microscopic level not the macroscopic
level human beings don't behave nearly
as locally and microscopically as water
molecules do they know about the
contacts that they are in so it's a
different story and maybe although I'm
not really sure maybe downward causation
is a useful idea in a situation like
that
David says I read the New Scientist
essential guide article entitled Beyond
The Big Bang from Einstein's Universe
essential guide number 10. you are
quoted as saying we used a half-assed
version of quantum mechanics when we do
cosmology
what would a full ass version of quantum
mechanics tied with cosmology look like
I didn't remember that quote but that's
a good quote I'm glad you brought that
up back from the back from the archives
David I think that was a long time ago
but I still agree with it I think
there's two senses in which we use
half-assed quantum mechanics when it
comes to cosmology
um one is the underlying attitude
towards Quantum foundations and the
other is what it is we are actually
quantizing so let's do the second one
first mostly when we do cosmology like
when you're predicting the density
perturbations in the cosmic microwave
background we're not doing quantum
gravity right because we don't really
know the rules for quantum gravity in
these circumstances people have tried
again hartle and Hawking with the wave
function of the universe and other
people Alex flanken and Andre Linde and
others have tried to do a quantum
gravity story about the origin of the
universe and the associated inflationary
fluctuations but we don't know what the
rules of that game are so it's a very
difficult game to play in instead we
imagine that the universe is expanding
and there's a classical description of
space-time the background space time and
then we quantize fields on that
classical background space time in these
fields that we quantize include small
fluctuations of the gravitational field
that allows us to predict the existence
of what we call tensor perturbations
gravitational wave perturbations caused
by quantum mechanics in inflation so we
can do that but you see how it's
half-assed right we're quantizing some
things we're not quantizing other things
the other FS aspect is that what do we
mean by quantum mechanics do we mean
fully ever ready in quantum mechanics do
we mean Copenhagen do we mean something
else with hidden variables this was
exactly the question that caused Hugh
Everett to come across the many worlds
interpretation because John Wheeler his
advisor asked him to quantize gravity
and he thought about the quantum theory
of the whole universe and he came to the
conclusion that the Copenhagen way of
talking about quantum mechanics with a
Quantum system being observed by a
classical measuring apparatus was
inadequate to the purposes of studying
the universe as a whole so that's why he
invented many worlds but and that
nevertheless
people today still kind of use
copenhagen-ish quantum rules to apply to
the early Universe in a way that is
entirely inappropriate so you know the
Copenhagen rules are perfectly fine when
we're looking at the kinds of
experiments that we look at in particle
physics or Atomic physics or other
things that inspired the Copenhagen
rules in the first place but they just
don't make sense when we talk about the
early Universe there's no one there
making measurements okay so a big part
of this traditional standard textbook
Quantum rules are what happens when a
measurement is made there's no one
making measurements in the early
universe and everadian has no problem
with this and I've already and says
there's no such thing as measurements
what there is is decoherence and
evolution unitary evolution of the full
Quantum wave function so people will say
in the early Universe you know there is
a probability distribution that the
density fluctuations look like a certain
thing where does that probability
distribution come from I mean I get what
the probability distribution is via the
born rule for measurement outcomes but
there's no one measuring things in the
early universe so I literally wrote a
paper about this with uh Kim body and
Jason Pollock For Better or For Worse we
looked at how you should correctly talk
about
Quantum fluctuations during Eternal
inflation okay because people talk about
them uh as if you know there was some
magical wave function collapsing device
that happened once every Hubble time and
there isn't so we asked you know what
would the correct way of doing it be and
it's a very I should have predicted this
ahead of time but we got the answer
which is it's almost no difference like
you can do it correctly and you can get
numbers and they slightly are different
than the numbers you do it that you get
by doing in the half-assed way but it's
not a big difference so we could have
gotten lucky and found that there was a
big difference between doing it
correctly and doing it in a half-assed
way but in that case we did not so you
know that's the life of a scientist so
be it
Daniel Donaldson says in the biggest
ideas in the universe you brought up the
opposing views on space substantivalism
and relationalism you noted that today
most physicists would sign with treating
space as a thing itself however you do
not indicate a preference yourself which
you normally do
which side do you feel is more valid or
likely understanding than the book you
also noted that we don't have the final
answer
well you know I'm in some sense not sure
that this will turn out to be a very
relevant question in some sense
um the idea of substantivalism space is
a thing all by itself versus
relationalism Space is a convenient way
of characterizing a whole bunch of
relationships between things in space
I'm not entirely sure that that's a good
distinction to make that's a relevant
distinction to make I'm not sure what
difference it makes okay but that is a
more esoteric philosophical question I
think that this question relates to more
down-to-earth physics questions about
what is space and so I think that in My
Views space should be thought of as a
convenient way to talk about
relationships between different
subsystems in the quantum mechanical
wave function and in that sense I am
closer to being a relationalist than a
substantivalist but in classical general
relativity it sounds very substantial
okay space and space time or things and
they have their own Dynamics and so
forth so the convenient the most correct
answer to this question might very well
depend on your level of analysis in some
sense I think they're probably deep down
relationalism is going to win but for
everyday physics you know predicting
gravitational wave signatures from ligo
substantivalism might be the way to go
Aryan Malek says is there an objective
definition of entropy not in terms of
emergent macrostates laplace's card
shark which I guess Arian just invented
wouldn't see entropy increasing in
shuffles because all shufflings are
equally ordered to her with laplace's
demons see objective increases or
decreases in entropy in the forward
reverse Direction since it always sees
the fully specified configuration of the
wave function for the universe the short
answer is uh no there is not an emergent
an objective definition of entropy not
in terms of emerging macrostates entropy
is by Construction in classical
statistical mechanics it is a higher
level emerging concept if you are
laplace's demon laplace's card charcoal
passes whoever you just know the
microstate of the universe you don't
need to talk about entropy because you
know everything entropy is a coarse
grained phenomenon by E whether you do
it as in what we call exposed facto the
boltzmannian way which is to Define
macro States and make equivalence
classes of microstates if they look
macroscopically similar and then s
equals K log W is the equation on
Boltzmann's tombstone or we do it in
what you would call the Gibbs Shannon
way and say I have a probability
distribution over microstates and S
equals minus the integral of uh P log p
in some sense either way there's a lack
of information that is important into
the definition of entropy so laplace's
demon wouldn't suffer from that
however there's one little footnote here
which is that quantum mechanics is a
little bit different the fun Neumann
entropy of a subsystem is a perfectly
well defined kind of entropy which says
in quantum mechanics because of
entanglement I can have perfect
information about a composite system A
system that has subsystem a and
subsystem b I know exactly the quantum
wave function for the whole system but
because of entanglement I there is no
such thing as it's not just that I don't
know there's no such thing as the unique
Quantum state of the subsystem there's a
density operator okay rather than a wave
function and that density operator can
be thought of as a statistical
superposition of different or
statistical combination I should say of
different pure wave function states but
there but it has an entropy and that
entropy is objective in the sense that
we can calculate what it is everyone
agrees on it what it is even if you know
know the complete wave function the
exact Quantum state of the combined
system so in quantum mechanics
subsystems have an objective entropy
even if the overall system does not and
even loposa demon would agree with that
Jeffrey Seagal says the discussion with
Rafael miliere was very stimulating near
the end he expressed a valid concern
that human rights and Sapient machine
rights might come into conflict I
suspect this question will become real
very soon since it seems likely that the
gpt4 connection numbers roughly match
the number of synapses in the human
brain 100 trillion to one quadrillion I
I would be interested in your thoughts
on the issue of human versus machine
rights I think this is an important
issue a complex one you know I don't
think that the comparison of synapses to
connection numbers is a very direct one
so I don't think that's immediately
relevant I think that we're going to
have to think more carefully more
carefully about what we mean by an agent
a person who deserves rights and it's
not something that you know legally or
even
casually we think about very carefully I
mean legally we need to Define very
carefully what we mean by a person but
we do so about you know is a certain
human being competent should we count
the collection of human beings like a
corporation as a person things like that
we do not go very far into asking
whether non-human beings are agents are
individuals are deserving of any kind of
rights now I am of the opinion that
right now even with gpt4 which is one of
the more advanced AI large language
models out there on the market I don't
think that we're even close
to saying that something is generally
intelligent or an agent not just is
there hallucination on the part of these
large language models they say things
with great confidence that are
completely untrue but there's an ability
to extrapolate away from the information
that we know about
um to contemplate to be creative that
they don't have yet they you know the
large language models are able to do
remarkably human-like things
because they are trained on what things
that have actually been done by humans
there's going to be much more that you
need I think to qualify something for
rights for example and I've said this
before many times the large language
model doesn't get upset if you don't
talk to it it doesn't get annoyed it
doesn't get frustrated it doesn't get
bored you know there's many features of
actual living beings that are not in
common with these large language models
that is not to say that they could not
be instantiated in artificial beings of
some sort or even to say that that won't
happen relatively quickly so I don't
know
what the criteria should be for giving
rights to some artificially generated
intelligence I do think that it's going
to require some thought and I think that
you know the the tricks that large
language models can do right now are not
up to the task but maybe we're close I
really don't know the the pace of
progress has been very very fast but I
would need to think about it more myself
before I would say anything with
confidence about when they should count
as persons
Nicola evanov says you mentioned in one
of your podcasts you are working on some
ideas as to why the notion of position
and not for example momentum is so
important in the macro world we live in
can you please elaborate on these ideas
yeah I wrote a paper
um somewhat recently with ashmeet Singh
former graduate student uh who is now a
professor and we talked it's the paper
on Quantum myriology which is asking the
question if you just have a Hilbert
space and a state Vector in it and you
know you start somewhere and let it
evolve is there a right way to divide up
all of Hilbert's space into subsystems
which you might call the system under
consideration and the environment and
the main Criterion we used was that we
wanted the system to have a classical
limit right we want to be able to
explain things in the real world like
the fact that you and I in the tables
and chairs around us act pretty
classically so we came up with some
criteria for doing that
and along the way a very important role
is played by how the environment
monitors the system you know if you
think as we already talked about
everything about a cat or a human being
in a room with light photons bumping off
of the system and air molecules Etc
there is a very you know you can write
down the interaction between the
environment and the system and what we
know in the real world is that when does
a photon of light interact with you well
when it hits you it bumps into you in
space okay that's a crucial feature of
what we call space
interestingly if you study classical
mechanics if you study the versions that
I explain in biggest ideas in the
universe volume one
you'll find a formulation of classical
mechanics called hamiltonian mechanics
which treats position and momentum on a
completely equal footing the fundamental
equations of hamiltonian mechanics do
not differentiate between positions and
momenta that's a little bit alien to us
because we are used to thinking of
positions as fundamental and you get a
momentum by taking the derivative of
position with respect to time to get the
velocity and you multiply the velocity
by the mass to get the momentum and we
therefore momentum is a derived quantity
and position is a fundamental one and
interestingly in the hamiltonian version
of classical mechanics that's just not
true there's a complete equivalence
between position and momentum but in the
real world there's not so
one can ask the question where does this
distinction between position and
momentum in the real world come from and
what we found and it's very tentative
and we're trying to think about how to
push it forward a little bit more but
what we found was that this in order to
get classical looking behavior of a
subsystem of a larger Quantum system
there needed to be a specific way that
the system is being monitored they're
basically the environment monitors some
variable in the system and you know
again this is a volume two of the
biggest ideas thing but we also talked
about it in something deeply hidden
there's something called the uncertainty
principle right in quantum mechanics
position and momentum cannot
simultaneously be exactly defined and
what that means is that if you think
about what you mean by position and
momentum they can't both be being
monitored by the environment at the same
time so the fact that something is being
monitored by the environment in order to
allow a quantum mechanical system to act
classically implies that you have to
pick one uh physician and momentum and
you know again a feature of the
hamiltonian formalism is that you can
call one variable position one very
momentum or even have some combination
of position momentum act as your
fundamental variables so the point is
that of these possible things to measure
you pick half of them and that is what
is being monitored by the environment
and that is what Expos facto we call
position we call location in space
you're only allowed to monitor one thing
and that's what we call position now it
very much depends on the laws of physics
on the hamiltonian itself that the
governs the laws of physics in the
quantum mechanical picture that there is
even something that would give rise to a
classical limit at all so we're not
saying that this necessarily happens
we're saying that it's a very
interesting thing from the hamiltonian
perspective classically by itself
without quantum mechanics the
hamiltonian could be any function you
like a position and momentum of these
two variables but our suggestion which
is very vague and we're trying to make
it more firm is that the kinds of
hamiltonians that arise as classical
limits of quantum mechanical
hamiltonians
who distinguish between position and
momentum they pick one out to be
monitored and to give rise to a robust
classical limit
I have no idea why the real world allows
for a classical limit at all that's
another level question but I think if
you want the classical limit there's
going to be a preferred variable and
we're going to call that the position
that is my current belief about this
question but again still working on it
Jim Murphy says I've watched your
biggest ideas videos but I'm still a bit
lost on how we describe a particle in
Quantum field theory in particular I'm
confused when you talk about the modes
of the feel I'm thinking of it as
breaking apart the field into a bunch of
sine waves using Fourier transforms but
there could be an infinite number of
sine waves required to describe the
field this leaves me wondering how
breaking apart the field into those
waves could describe different numbers
of particles which of the sine waves are
relevant when determining whether the
field describes one particle or two
particles and so on
I think it's a very good question this
is like a tricky thing that I'm trying
I'm struggling with right now in writing
the book version of uh the biggest ideas
of videos that the volume 2 will be on
Quantum quanta and Fields and mostly
field Theory and particle physics so why
does a quantized classical field look
like particles to us and I think the
confusion here is that it well let's
back up a little bit the classical field
as you correctly say can be decomposed
into a bunch of sine waves using Fourier
transform so rather than giving you the
value of the field at every point in
space I can give you the value of the
field the contribution to the field the
configuration from different sine waves
with different amplitudes and different
wavelengths and in Quantum field Theory
what happens is that for each mode for
each wavelength that is contributing to
the classical field it can have its own
Quantum State you can separately and
this is true in the limit where the
field is not interacting or being
complicated that's why Quantum field
theory is hard because there are
interactions in the real world but if
you just simplify your life and look at
free fields that are not interacting
each mode
behaves all by itself and it behaves in
such a way that it looks like a simple
harmonic oscillator and a simple
harmonic oscillator has energy levels
the vacuum State the first excited state
the second excited state and so forth
and so what we mean by a particle
in Quantum field theory is a Quantum
state which has the first excited state
of a number of modes so it's not that if
I if I take two modes and I construct a
Quantum state where one mode is in its
first excited state and another mode is
in its first excited state that's not
two particles that's one particle whose
wave function is a superposition of
those two modes right so basically when
you create a wave packet or some thing
that has a spatial profile that is
representing a single particle it is a
superposition of many different modes
each in their first excited state if
there are many different modes in there
second excited state we would call those
two particles and you can actually do a
little bit of manipulation to explain
why that resembles what you and I know
as two particle systems and so forth if
you have a superposition where some
modes are in their vacuum State and some
other modes are in their first excited
state you would call that a super
position of zero particles in one
particle okay so there is a translation
there's a dictionary that goes back and
forth between the quantum field Theory
language and the particle language and
that's kind of one of the miraculous fun
things about Quantum field Theory
Paul Larkin says there is much discussed
in physics about extra dimensions of
space EG and string theory having nine
space and one time Dimension why do we
can generally consider only one time
Dimension and not multiple is this an
area of research and if so in what ways
and if so why not it is an area of
research it talked bars at USC is the
person who has really spent the most
time thinking about multiple time
Dimensions but naively it just doesn't
work everything breaks down when you
have two time Dimensions you can go in
Loops in time very very easily right you
can just walk in a circle in time rather
than going forward in time there's also
generally speaking and maybe you can
work hard to get around this but
generally speaking the energy of the
system is unbounded below so nothing is
stable everything runs away it's just a
complete mess it looks nothing like the
real world so intellectually you can
just sort of ask can I really work hard
to make a version of this that does look
like the real world but it's hard and
it's pretty unconvinced saying and
there's no real motivation for it
there's no experiment that we've done
that that is better explained by having
multiple time Dimensions than not
whereas with spatial Dimensions it's
very easy to hide them you just make
them small and then you can't see them
and you get you get away that's not true
with extra time dimensions and there's
motivation for the extra dimensions of
space namely that they are demanded by
string theory and string theory is a
finite theory of quantum gravity so
there's some motivation for doing it so
there are good reasons out there why we
spend a lot more time talking about
extra dimensions of space than extra
dimensions of time
I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing it
correctly but I'm trying says in from
eternity to here you have a picture to
illustrate closed time like curves that
reminded me so much of braid theory is
brain Theory at all involved in the
analysis of ctcs
short answer no
long answer maybe that's a little bit
you know it's two syllables rather than
just one you know I don't know a lot
about raid Theory when we draw pictures
of closed time like curves we are
necessarily being a little bit uh hand
wavy you know we're going to draw some
of the closed timeline curves but not
all of them whenever you draw a picture
of a space time and try to make it
visually clear to the uh Seer The
Observer of the picture then you're
making some compromises and
in the real world it's hard enough to
make one set of close time like curves
right like one topologically distinct
region of space-time which is foliated
by closed time-like curves
um to make it interesting topologically
so that you have you know some close
time like curves that braid around
others in some interesting way well
that's even harder and the motivation
once again as for the previous question
the motivation is pretty low for
something like that so as far as I know
there's not been any direct important
application of brain Theory to the
analysis of closed timeline curves but
you know if we discover some or if we
have a good reason why it should be
there then things will be different
ARCA Lucas says have you ever played
Dungeons and Dragons or other tabletop
role-playing games and if so what do you
think
sure you know I mean I'm pretty old I'm
the original generation of course I
played DND when I was in junior high
school and maybe even high school I
forget exactly what the years were but
you know around then uh we're talking
late 70s early 80s right that was the
first wave of enthusiasm and I like
being the dungeon master more than I
like being a player and you know we
didn't always obey the rules exactly and
things like that but we had a lot of fun
um when I see and and hear about people
playing it now I haven't played it for
many years or even decades
um I am always struck by how I mean
probably there's a huge selection effect
right that I'm I'm hearing about people
who are really into it and really good
at it but they're way better
storytellers than I ever was you know
the dungeon master I was really devoted
to coming up with clever puzzles and
tricks and challenges for my players to
solve but not you know telling a
convincing narrative story so much so I
think that's how I would be different if
I were doing it now but you know again
it's an investment you have to like put
some time into it
um I I have no objections to the idea
that I would ever play it again but I
have other things going on right now so
it's I don't see it happening anytime
soon
Andre dinu asks a priority question you
have remarked in the past the quantum
field theory is a local Theory Quantum
field theory is based on partial
differential equations therefore the
properties of a Quantum field at any
given point depend only on the
properties of the fields in its
immediate vicinity however Bell's
theorem is an indication that quantum
mechanics in general is not local at
least not in it is not compatible with
local hidden variable theories Quantum
field theory is only one type of quantum
theory but it is the most advanced
version of quantum mechanics how is it
then possible the quantum field theory
is a local Theory but quantum mechanics
in general is non-local good I like this
question because it's easy to answer
it's an important question but it is one
which the answer is very clear namely
that when we say the quantum field
theory is local to be perfectly honest
we're not talking about quantum
mechanics we're talking about the
unitary Evolution the evolution of the
of the quantum field Theory when it is
not being observed you know that in
quantum mechanics in general whether
it's Quantum field Theory or anything
else we have separate sets of rules for
what the quantum state does when it is
not being observed and when it is being
observed in many worlds what we mean by
being observed is just Deco hearing and
branching Etc but still that's okay we
can use those words Bell's theorem is
entirely about correlations of measured
Quantum States you can't do Bell's
theorem without talking about
measurement and collapse of the wave
function okay so when you say Quantum
field theory is local that is a
statement about the Dynamics of the
theory while it is not being measured
when you say Bell's theorem you're
making a statement about correlations
between quantities when they are
measured so there's absolutely no
um contradiction there they're just
talking about two very different things
David Maxwell says You seem to do so
much full-time Professor podcaster
continually learning more broadly I
honestly don't know where you find the
time are you willing to give some
estimates of what you spend your time on
both professional and personal is part
of it that many of these things are done
in your leisure time
um yeah I guess that's part of it look
you know for better for worse I don't
think that
I don't like to talk too much about you
know my system or my way of doing things
because I I think it's bad for other
people to think that there's some right
way to do things there's many different
good ways of doing things and people
need to find their own way to find what
works for them sometimes people ask me
like what is your routine for writing a
book and I got I Just Gotta Laugh
there's no routine like whenever I can
find the time and the inspiration then I
work on the book that's my routine
um in terms of dividing things up you
know the podcast is a special case like
the podcast is a weird thing which is
not really academic work not even really
book writing which is kind of
semi-academic certainly it's not
research it's intellectual work you know
I do pick people to have on the podcast
because I want to learn something from
them and discussions on the podcast can
bleed into my more scholarly academic
interests but it's not something that is
recognized by The Establishment as
academic work and I so I work hard to to
the Limit my podcasting time I work very
very hard to make sure that on average
from week to week I don't spend more
than one full day's worth of effort on
the podcast in terms of other things
um
you know book writing and whatever that
just comes and goes very dramatically
there are times when it's book writing
time and you know weeks go by when I
don't really do anything other than work
on the books there's other times when
I'm being a professor and I'm teaching
and you know I gotta write that lecture
gotta read those papers grade those
papers talk to those students and the
The crucial part of the question the
interesting part of the question here is
how many of these things are done in
your leisure time and you know look I'm
in a very very privileged special
situation where there's not a lot of
hard and fast distinction between my
leisure time and my work time I love
what I do for a living and I'm very very
lucky to be like that I'm not someone
who thinks that you need to love what
you do I think that there's plenty of
people who very uh respectfully and
legitimately work because they need to
earn a living that's completely fine and
we should honor that but I am lucky
enough to be able to earn money doing
what I love doing so I spend a lot of of
time doing the various things that I do
and I you know whether it's reading or
thinking or you know now relearning
Python and programming with help from AI
uh extensions and so forth you know
that's fun for me I like it the podcast
is fun for me so I don't draw a hard and
fast distinction between my leisure time
and my work time sometimes my leisure
time is you know cooking dinner or
sitting down and watching Colombo or
whatever and that's clearly pretty
clearly leisure time so I do have
Leisure Time don't worry but uh I don't
really count up how much of it I spend
or how many hours of the day are devoted
to that
Jesse rimler said I enjoyed your podcast
episode with Rafael miliere on AI at one
point miliere says that tpt's
architecture is not comparable to the
human brain in terms of how it actually
functions that is a neural network does
not actually work the way our neurons
work then he goes on to speculate how we
may use these networks to learn about
the human mind whether we are born with
innate grammar for example isn't this a
contradiction we don't use airplanes to
study the flight of birds well I don't
think it's a contradiction I just think
it's the lesson here is that it's not
going to be easy or obvious or
straightforward that doesn't mean it
can't happen this is why it's work to do
this kind of research there's a lot that
we do know about the human brain and a
lot that we don't know about it neural
networks are not exactly the same as the
way that your neurons work in your real
brain but they were inspired by it you
know the neurons came first before
neural networks did and people looked at
how the neurons worked and said hmm you
know maybe we can make something like a
computer program that works in a similar
way they don't work in exactly the same
way but there's a relationship there I
think what uh Raphael is probably
getting at is the fact that as we
discussed earlier in the podcast we
train our neural networks our deep
Learning Network or whatever it is and
it learns and it gains capacities to do
certain things and we can talk about the
capacities it has and then once that
happens we can go in and look it's
actually hard to do but in principle we
can go in and look and ask what's going
on in the neural network what is
happening inside when it is parsing a
sentence or something like that there is
no guarantee that what we find when we
do that is directly applicable to what
goes on in the human brain but there's
enough open questions about what goes on
in the human brain that we can say
can we be inspired can we get an
interesting uh idea for what is going on
in the human brain that we might not
otherwise have thought of before you
know it's much like I think about the
physics of democracy it's not that I
think that you should think about
democracy like a physicist
it's that maybe you get inspired by
thinking about things we've learned from
physics when we're also trying to
understand this very very difficult
thing which is how a democracy or
Society works I think it's a very
similar thing in the relationship
between neural networks and actual
neurons
Casey Mahone says this is a bit of a
basic question but I realize that I
don't fully understand how solid objects
work something like water makes sense to
me because the molecules are bound
together electrically but in general the
molecules bounce off of one another I
suppose I can also understand things
like plastic being made of long
molecules that can rotate around and get
stuck on each other but how does
something like a chair Stay Together are
the intermolecular forces really that
strong
I'm not going to be able to give you the
world's best answer to this this is not
the kind of physics that is my personal
specialty but I think that you've
already answered it it is intermolecular
forces and it does have something to do
with the particular molecules that
you're talking about if you're talking
about something like why is iron solid
it's roughly speaking because the
molecules take on more or less a
crystalline lattice kind of shape inside
the iron it's an individual iron atoms
okay they arrange each other why because
of the tiny electromagnetic forces
between the different atoms you have to
go into some work to show exactly what
those what the sizes and shapes and
functions of those electromagnetic
forces are because iron atoms are have a
little bit of complication in them
they're not super complicated but
there's a little bit of complication
there likewise for ice when we have
water molecules or something like that
whereas in a chair if your chair is made
of wood rather than iron then it's more
like plastic right because wood is an
organic material and there's cellulose
in it and those are long molecules and
they gain tensile strength by braiding
together and wrapping together in
interesting ways there's also the
separate question of why atoms and
molecules themselves take up space and
that goes into deep questions about the
poly Exclusion Principle and fermions
and Quantum field Theory and spin
statistics and things like that but
roughly speaking I don't think you
should be surprised that objects are
solid because you know when
well let's put it this way
you might think well the forces between
individual molecules are very small so
how do they create a large solid object
and the answer is there's a lot of
molecules and they build up and you have
to run the numbers you can't just say
well the forces between two molecules
aren't that big therefore it makes no
sense that the table is solid right you
have to be a little bit more
quantitative and careful than that and I
promise you that if you are you will
find that your table is solid as it
should be it does not violate the laws
of physics
Robert zanelli says you've written an
interesting paper on extremo black holes
in an extremal black hole temperature
and surface gravity goes to zero
although it is unlikely a black hole can
become extreme wool assuming this is
possible what are the gr predictions for
the gravitational field inside the
merged Horizons and at a distance beyond
the merge Horizons so I'm not sure how
to answer this question
um I I included it in the questions
being answered because
Robert worked very hard to get he was
struggling with the patreon being
obstreperous and and breaking the
question into little pieces so you know
I think it deserves an answer but the
answer is you know let's back up a
little bit an extremal black hole for
those of you who don't know is an
example of a black hole where the mass
is being balanced by something else so
the simplest example is electric charge
okay if I have two black holes and
they're both both positively charged
then the gravitational field is going to
attract the two black holes together but
the positive charge on both is going to
repel them and you can ask you know when
does it balance when does it become
equally big and it turns out that it
balances when you have what is called an
extremo black hole there is a largest
possible amount of electric charge that
you can put into a black hole and when
that happens it's called extremol
in fact we think that in practice that's
never going to happen I mean not just
astrophysically but if you try to make
one you would have a lot of difficulty
think about it I have a black hole that
is positively charged I'm trying to
charge it even more by throwing a proton
into it but that proton is being
repelled very strongly by the
electromagnetic field there so it's hard
to make extremely black holes
nevertheless they are theoretically very
interesting so I wrote a paper with
Matthew Johnson and Lisa Randall where
we discussed some puzzles
about the limit uh that you take to get
to an extremal black hole it turns out
that if you start with a black hole that
is not quite extremal so it has some
electric charge but not enough to be
extremal and then you look at the
space-time diagram of that almost
extremo black hole versus the space-time
diagram of an actually extremal black
hole they look very different there's a
whole region where is it's present in
the non-extremal black hole but it's not
present in the extreme old black hole
and between us Lisa and Matt and I
called this region Whoville after the Dr
Seuss book we didn't we didn't put that
into the final paper but when we were
writing the paper we called it the
Whoville paper and we showed that this
whole region sort of discontinuously
disappears when you hit the extreme
limit and that's part of why it's hard
to make an extremo black hole and maybe
it helps explain some of the weird
features of extremo black holes but to
the actual question being asked here
what are the gr predictions I mean I'm
not sure what you what you want we have
an exact solution that you can find in
my general relativity textbook for what
the metric and therefore the
gravitational field looks like inside an
extremal black hole you know if you're
yourself not electrically charged then
you just fall into it and there's a
horizon and you can't get out just like
any other black hole so the
gravitational field for uncharged
objects is just not that different
especially outside the internal
structure is more complicated but as we
discussed when we're talking about Roy
Kerr's question
no one should believe the internal
structures that you get from taking
overly seriously these Exact Solutions
to general relativity the real world is
going to be messier than that
Julie Mars says I enjoyed the last
interview with Rafael miliere the
emergence of a the new breed of AI tools
are exciting and thought-provoking it
appears to me that we are experiencing
something like the Advent of personal
Computing and the internet in this case
though the changes appear to be vastly
accelerated in comparison I'm optimistic
about these new tools what are your
thoughts on the subject after speaking
with miliere uh you know I do think it's
important to keep in mind that what
Rafael and I were talking about was this
question which is at the intersection of
computer science and philosophy which is
to what extent should we think about
these existing AI models as thinking
okay we didn't really delve into the
technology questions of how these tools
are going to be used we did not delve
into what are the dangers what are the
prospects these are all very very
interesting questions but we already
gone on two hours in that podcast and so
uh we didn't cover those that's okay
um
yes you're right I agree with you Julie
that the change is the rate of change
because of these new AI tools is much
faster seems to be much faster than the
rate of change was when we introduced
personal Computing or the internet part
of that is a bootstrap effect right like
the rate of change that we would be
witnessing uh if AI had come before the
internet might appear to be much slower
but because of the internet we are aware
of these changes that are happening very
rapidly and also something like the rate
of change of progress is always hard to
quantify right we might find 100 years
from now that we were still just getting
started right now in these years right
now but um I do think so I'm very bad at
predicting technological change I think
I've told this story before but when the
first web browsers came on the scene
um
NCSA Mosaic the first graphical web
browser and then Netscape after that I
was very much excited by this this is
the 1990s I was very much
um enthusiastic and convinced that this
was going to change the world
and I try to convince other people that
it was going to change the world and I
completely failed because when they said
well how will it change the world I was
very bad I was unable to articulate why
that would happen I explained that you
could order a pizza over the internet
and they're like I have all the
technology I need to wear a pizza
already I do not need to do it using a a
fancy bit of Technology
um so I am convinced that these AI tools
will be pretty much ubiquitous they're
going to be everywhere they're going to
help you write they're going to help you
program but they're also going to help
you compose music they're going to help
schedule Airlines and buy tickets and
plan your vacation and many things but I
don't know what I don't know what uh I I
admit my I have enough humility to admit
that I'm bad at predicting that so I can
see that they will be everywhere that
they'll be in all sorts of tools they
already are right you know Siri and
Alexa are examples of AI things even
Google search and Bing and things like
that are AI based to some extent
those particular examples are
intentionally throttled down you know
you can't get the best AIS in Siri or
Alexa because we don't yet know what the
best AIS will do under certain
circumstances I think there's a lot to
worry about in terms of the safety and
things like that I think that we it's
almost hopeless to imagine
Banning certain kinds of research or
forbidding certain kinds of AI in
certain kinds of situations because
human beings are just always going to
get around that that's just a almost
hopeless task I do think and hope that
we should think seriously about what we
let the AIS do what we do to preserve
safety
and things like that I'm not at all
convinced we're going to do that just as
we said earlier that we're very bad at
protecting our own privacy we're also
very bad at slowing down the rate of
cool progress because maybe it will be
dangerous we human beings just aren't
good at that so I think it's a
legitimate worry that things are that
they'll be disastrous consequences even
as there are also very good consequences
you know there's still ongoing debates
about whether social media and
smartphones Etc make people sad overall
like obviously there's they're hugely
beneficial for some reasons but there's
at least some evidence that might be on
the right track that overall they make
our quality of life worse
so I don't know I don't think we're very
good at
stepping back taking a breath and
looking at the long-term implications of
things carefully we're just short-term
bumbling into the next cool thing kind
of people that's what we do not I'm not
saying we should do it that way but
that's what we do and I bet that's what
we're gonna do with AI
Robert weinman says philosophy has
caught my interest Hegel is often quoted
so I decided to read some totally
incomprehensible I read people's
analyzes they seem reasonable but I
still can't make sense of the stuff
Hegel wrote do you have any suggestions
I did discover what popper thinks of it
so I don't feel too dumb well you know
I'm a big fan of philosophy overall but
I am also absolutely convinced that
philosophy has an enormous dynamic range
in the sense that you know the worst
physics papers out there are still
pretty okay whereas the worst philosophy
papers out there are just anti-useful
are actually harmful whereas the best
philosophy papers are amazing really
crucially important so Hegel is you know
the standard Bearer for a kind of
philosophy that I personally find
completely useless I have zero interest
in anything Hegel ever said someone like
imanuel Kant uh much of what he said I
struggle to see why it is important or
useful or comprehensible but others I
can see why yes you absolutely need or
this is absolutely insightful and and
helpful so the fact that you didn't get
anything out of Hegel I wouldn't worry
about that at all it depends very much
on what questions you are interested in
ahead of time different philosophers
have different things that they care
about you know if you're interested in
Bertrand Russell you might not be
interested in Simone de bouvar you know
who knows so I think that you have to
rather than just saying like let's read
philosophy you have to ask ask yourself
what are the philosophical questions
that I would like the answer to get to
have a little motivation there it's
going to be hard to read just about any
philosopher
um and in terms of you know that that's
why I don't have suggestions I think
it's going to depend very much on what
you care about you know if you read more
or less contemporary let's say 20th
century philosophers whether they're
living people like David Thomas
um or recently living people like Carl
popper or Bertrand Russell or Simone de
bouvoir or Quine or Putnam or whatever
um Richard wardy you know just depends
on your interests they will generally
engage with previous philosophers so you
can kind of work your way backwards
right you can read some relatively
recent people figure out who the ones
that you like are and then dig into the
ones who they talk about right who they
think are interesting and important to
engage with and or you could go the
other way you could just read Plato and
Aristotle or you could read the classics
of uh Chinese philosophy and taoism or
Confucianism or Indian philosophy or
whatever see what engages with you
Buddhist philosophy
um because it is there's no like
set five things that everybody should
read it's going to depend a lot on on
what you care about
um finally of course you know there's
more specific things not
you know I have this idiosyncratic
belief that the overlap between science
and philosophy is actually way more
important than it has been taken to be
I think that and now I'm just sort of
babbling so don't it's been a long AMA
here so don't take me too seriously here
but you know there have been absolutely
attempts in the history of philosophy to
make it more scientific right The
Logical positivists famously try to make
science uh the Paradigm for doing
philosophy and I don't think that's the
right answer but I do think that there
should be way more interaction between
scientific insights about the world and
philosophical insights about the world I
mean that's why I'm doing what I'm doing
with my new job at Johns Hopkins I think
there's a lot of speaking of low-hanging
fruit as we did before here's a place
where there's a lot of low-hanging fruit
I tend to think that
um in current contemporary philosophy
there is philosophy of biology
philosophy of physics things like that
and there are also areas like
mathematical logic or epistemology or
metaphysics which interact and engage
with science but there could be a lot
more I think there's a lot more insight
to begin gained by really taking both
seriously at the same time and people
don't do that so anyway that's my little
uh digression to say that read modern
philosophers of science read David
Albert and David Wallace or Tim Maudlin
um or Janet Ismail Or Glory Paul who we
had on the podcast before these are
people who are taking science very
seriously and I think that one big thing
in the decades to come is that these
kinds of scholarly work will have a much
bigger impact on the rest of philosophy
that's what I'm looking forward to
James Tyler can says I could use some
advice I have a masters in linguistics
and I'm part way through a PhD in the
same subject however I've been
dissatisfied with the research currently
being done in the field the replication
crisis and I'm looking for something new
I'm considering doing a masters in
computer science in the UK because it's
a one-year degree and would open up new
possibilities do you think it would be
unwise to leave my current PhD to go
after a second Masters in the hope of
opening up my job prospects so I always
address questions like this with a great
deal of trepidation because advice is
impossible to give for career choices
like this because different people are
different and I don't know everything
about your situation having said that
although I do think that getting a PhD
is intrinsically a useful thing to do
it's kind of training in research and
scholarship and knowledge that is in
principle very useful no matter what you
end up to go and do
if you want to use that PhD to launch a
career in that area then you had better
love what you're doing I don't think you
know getting a PhD is not something you
reluctantly do because you can't think
of anything else to do or you don't have
any other options I think that you
really need to be passionate about what
you're diving into a PhD is a lot of
your life if it's just even if it's just
five years you know that's a significant
fraction of your life and certainly a
lot of work and angst along the way so
if you already know that you're
sufficiently dissatisfied with the kind
of research going on in this field that
you're tempted by another career switch
or a change of focus in your scholarly
interests then my very rough inclination
would be to say yes go for it to change
your mind now do it sooner rather than
later you kind of gotta love what you do
on the academic track and and getting a
PhD is part of that so that would be my
very rough
said with great
um you know softness that don't be too
definitive about it but that's roughly
the direction which I would lean
Samuel Benjamin says following your call
for questions each month on patreon I
often scroll through them as they come
in liking or Harding the ones I find
interesting do the number of likes or
Hearts On Any Given question ever
influence your decision to answer them
even if it doesn't would you encourage
my continued use of this function and
why
well I will tell you the honest sad
truth they have very very little impact
on my decision to answer them and that's
not because I don't care about them it's
just a down-to-earth technological
feature namely that the way that I go
about figuring out what questions to ask
Etc is I take the whole list of comments
and I cut and paste it into a text file
where I can both edit the questions down
because some people like to ramble on
when they're asking questions and I can
you know rearrange them to put them in
in an order that I like and of course I
can delete the ones that I'm not going
to get a chance to get around to and
when I do that cutting and pasting the
number of likes doesn't come with me so
I just don't know uh I could put more
work into figuring out which ones were
highly liked but I I just don't sorry
about that now there is one option
which is you can leave a comment on the
comment right you can leave a comment on
the question and you can say oh I really
really like this question
that will generally get transferred in
my cutting and pasting and I will see it
and there have been cases where I was
gonna not answer a question but then
like two people said oh yes this is a
great question I hope he answers this
one and so I did answer it for that
reason so if you really care about a
certain question being uh valuable just
leave a comment on the comment and say
yeah I really hope that this question
gets answered I'm very interested in
this also
Jeff B says I just watched a video that
really helped me understand gauge Fields
so I guess the idea is that what appears
to us as forces is really a warping in
some sort of space for Gravity it is
literally space time but for charge it
could be warping in charge space this is
similar to forces we often think of as
fictitious like the Coriolis force is
there a profound difference between
these two ideas or is it just easier for
us to explain away the Coriolis for us
as fictitious because it is so
macroscopic
you know um
I think that there's something there but
I don't love the analogy between gauge
Theory forces and fictitious forces I
think the you've got the idea you know
your idea of warping in some sort of
space is exactly right but I don't
personally think of those as fictitious
forces I mean it's almost exactly like a
ball rolling down a hill right if you
have some undulating landscape of Hills
and Valleys and put a ball on it and the
ball rolls downward on the hill and then
comes back up and decelerates Etc I
don't think those I don't think of those
as fictitious forces I think of those as
just forces right the slope of the Hill
gives rise to a force a fictitious Force
comes about because we're in some
non-inertial reference frame like we're
in a rotating reference frame or
something like that but there is exists
another reference frame the inertial one
where you don't see the force okay for
these kinds of forces there's no
reference frame you can go into where
they disappear they are real they really
exist out there so I do think that they
have to do with curvature with slopes
with derivatives of some background
Fields I don't think that it's helpful
to think of them as fictitious
Sandro Snooki says what kinds of physics
will be featured in your upcoming book
physics of democracy I suspect that
there will be a fair bit of statistical
mechanics but probably little to no
quantum theory or relativity what makes
certain branches of physics useful in
the social sciences and others not
I think you know you're kind of
answering your own question I think you
kind of know what the answer is you just
want me to say it out loud so you're
exactly right there'll be a fair bit of
statistical mechanics there will be some
Network theories some percolation Theory
phase transitions things like that some
emergence all of these have in common
that what they're doing is talking about
the relationship of microscopic things
to macroscopic things and that's why I
think that there is something called the
physics of democracy because that is
another example where you have
microscopic things and macroscopic
things the microscopic things now are
people the macroscopic things are
countries or nations or governments or
whatever as a very obvious uh
parallelism there and so I think that
you can borrow ideas and Inspirations
from the physics analysis of these
things which are inevitably simpler and
in toy models spherical cow kind of
language and maybe be inspired to get
some insights onto the behavior of
social systems so there will be no
quantum theory or relative D why not
well
generally speaking quantum theory and
relativity
aren't important for the studying the
aggregate behavior of systems which
themselves are very classical and
non-relativistic right human beings are
pretty darn classical they might be
probabilistic they might you might say
that the best theory we have of an
individual human behavior has some
stochastic element to it that's fine but
it's not quantum mechanical it's not
that there are superpositions or
interference or entanglement or anything
like that in human beings likewise you
don't need relativity people are moving
slowly compared to the speed of light
right Newtonian space time is more or
less fine so I think there's a specific
kind of physics that is very very
relevant to social situations but
relativity in and quantum mechanics
aren't going to be part of it there's
other books I've written about
relativity and quantum mechanics so I
don't feel like I'm depriving you of
anything there
Sean Bentley says often I read science
articles about the usage of quantum
entanglement for passing information I
can grasp how it could make information
passing more secure but wanted to make
sure I understood correctly that there
should be no way to use it for passing
information faster than the speed of
light is this true yes this is
completely true in fact it is so true I
wouldn't personally state it as using
quantum entanglement for passing
information the passing of information
is generally completely classical you
have to send a signal from here to there
somehow
things can be entangled and the
existence of entanglement can imply
correlations between what we see when we
measure it that's Belle's theorem or epr
or whatever but it does not constitute
passing information because if I am
Alice and I'm measuring my spin here and
my spin is entangled with Bob spin I can
measure it and get an outcome and
therefore know what Bob will see but Bob
doesn't know what my measurement outcome
is so his predictions don't change when
I make that measurement so no
information passes back and forth so I
would say that you're exactly right
in the broader superstructure of
information sharing entanglement is very
important or could be very important
whether it's in encryption or keeping
things safe from eavesdropping and stuff
like that entanglement can serve a
purpose but in the actual passage of
information from point A to point B it
doesn't really help
okay we have one question left from Pete
Harlan who says I come over for dinner
you ask me if I'd like a cocktail and I
say yes I'd love your favorite Martini
what do you bring me
well I'm a big Martini guy so this is a
great question except that even though I
am a big Martini guy I'm not that
uptight about it honestly you know I
know there are people in cocktail land
just as in many other
aesthetic
endeavors where they're going to insist
on the rightness of their preferences
but I I am truly deep down a
subjectivist about these things I might
make a certain kind of Martini but I'm
actually happy to have different kinds
of martinis and if you like a different
kind of Martini I will I will go
um to try to make you happy my own
personal martinis are going to be not
too dry so there will be gin and a
non-negligible amount of uh vermouth so
well it certainly won't be vodka let's
put it that way because gin is just more
interesting than vodka in fact I have a
little kit that helps me make my own gin
not by having a still or anything like
that but basically what gin is to some
approximation is vodka which you then
flavor with Botanicals and you can do
that yourself at home the reason why
people don't do it more often is because
it generally colors your vodka when you
turn it into gin with the juniper
berries and the other kinds of
Botanicals and the professional gym
maker will then clarify the Gin to make
it look completely transparent but at
home you're not going to be able to do
that
but the flavors are important to me so I
don't see why anyone would ever want a
vodka martini this is going against my
previous
subjective inclinations but there you go
I'm going to be honest with you and not
too dry because I think that I don't
want to just drink cold gin that's not a
cocktail I mean that's a fine thing to
do if you're in the mood for that but
that's not a martini that's just gin the
wonderfulness about a cocktail is that
you're blending different ingredients
together and they balance each other and
they play a role so I would be you know
four to one or five to one in Gin versus
um vermouth uh dry vermouth it is so one
thing the the idea that so dryness by
the way
if you're not a cocktail person out
there
dryness has two slightly different but
very related
connotations here one is dry is the
opposite of sweet in cocktail land so
there is sweet vermouth which is
generally the red vermouths but there's
also dry vermouth which is not sweet
which is the clear vermouth and the
green bottles okay but then specifically
in Martini land dryness just means how
much for mousse do you have in there so
almost everyone who's going to put
vermouth in their Martini at all is
going to use dry vermouth but the drier
it means less
vermouth at all so a dry martini has
less vermouth than a not dry martini and
there's this kind of Macho feeling that
the less vermouth you have the better
because the Gin is what it's all about
and I completely disagree with that but
there's a feeling out there so when I
order a Martini in a restaurant or a bar
I need to specify not too dry you don't
want it like half and half or whatever
but I don't want to be unable to taste
the vermouth and also I don't want like
a dirty martini with olive juice or
anything like that you want the
garnishes to be there and to be
noticeable but not too overpower so a
couple of Olives I'm very happy with you
know garlic stuffed or jalapeno stuffed
olives or just a twist twist sort of
looks better aesthetically but doesn't
give as much taste to it so it depends
on what I'm in the mood for like I said
uh St George's terroir gin is my current
favorite but I will be honest that I
haven't
um really tried to explore every single
kind of gin out there in the world there
is a fun gin called Indigo that is
colored blue that if you want to make a
blue colored martini it just tastes like
gin it doesn't taste blue I don't know
what that would mean it does taste like
blueberries but uh you can make a Blue
Martini which in that case I would
strongly recommend going for the twist
to decorate it rather than the olives
the green olives just don't look good in
the Blue Martini but the yellow Twist of
lemon peel looks great so there you go
it depends on what I have on hand what
mood I'm in and what do you want and I
think that's the way our aesthetic
choices should be handled so with that
thanks as always for supporting
mindscape I appreciate it very much
thanks for sitting around for this long
set of AMA questions and I doubt that
any of the climate change denialists
have stuck around this long but if you
have I hope that you were at least
mildly entertained thanks I'll talk to
you next month
[Music]
la la